GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE I
APOLOGIZE FOR THE LATENESS-
WE'RE CONTINUE TO REQUIRE THE
MAST BE WORN BY EVERYONE IN
THIS ROOM AND INSIDE THE
BUILDING IF YOU DO NOT HAVE A
MASK. YOU CAN PROVIDE ONE FOR
YOU. WE HAVE A FEW DIFFERENT
OPTIONS FOR WITNESSES TESTIMONY
TODAY IF ANYONE LIKE TO TESTIFY
ON A BILL. PLEASE LISTEN FOR MY
PROMPT TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. YOU CAN EXIT THE HEARING
ROOM ONCE YOU'RE DONE-
TESTIFYING TO RETURN YOUR SEATS
FOR DIAL IN WITNESSES HERE
USING A MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE THROUGH WHICH ANY
WITNESS CAN TESTIFY ON A BILL.
THE CALL IN NUMBER IS. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE
FOUR TWO ZERO TWO YOU CAN ALSO
FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEES WEBSITE AS WELL AS
ON YOUR SCREEN TELEVISION
SCREEN. IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
PLEASE DO SO WHEN THE AUTHOR OF
THE BILL YOU'RE TESTIFYING
BEGINS THEIR BILL PRESENTATION.
YEAH OPERATE ONLINE WILL GIVE
YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACE IN THE QUEUE. IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE THIS INCLUDES
MUTING YOUR LIVE STREAM
BROADCAST AND- YOUR SMART
DEVICES. PLEASE NOTE IF YOU ARE
A PRIMARY WITNESS PROVIDING
TESTIMONY. YOUR REMAIN ON A
LIFELINE AND WILL NEED TO MUTE
YOUR DEVICE UNTIL YOU'RE CALLED
ON TO SPEAK. IF YOU'RE HAVING
ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE PHONE
SERVICE PLEASE CALL THE
COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE SIX.
THREE ONE NINE THREE NINE FIVE
EIGHT MY STUFF WILL BE THERE TO
HELP YOU. WE'RE ALSO ACCEPTING
WRITTEN TESTIMONY THROUGH THE
POSITION LETTER PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR BEARING WITH US
AS WE CONTINUES USING METHODS
TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA WHILE ALSO BEING
MINDFUL RESPECTFUL OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS WE STILL
FACE. NOW LET'S COVER THE
GROUND RULES FOR APPROPRIATE
CONDUCT. ASSEMBLY HAS X.
EXPERIENCE A NUMBER OF
DISRUPTIONS TO COMMITTEE
EMPLOYER PROCEEDINGS IN THE
LAST YEAR'S. CONDUCT CONDUCT
THE CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS
DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE IMPEDES
THE ORDERLY CONDUCT OF THE
HEARING IS PROHIBITED. SUCH
CONDUCT MAY INCLUDE REMOVING A
MASK OF HIS INPUT ABOUT DONE
TALKING OR MAKING LOUD NOISES
FROM THE AUDIENCE. UTTERING
LOUD THREATENING OR ABUSIVE
LANGUAGE SPEAKING LONGER THAN A
LOT TIME ALLOTTED. EXTENDED
DISCUSSION ON MATTERS NOT
RELATED TO THE SUBJECT OF THE
HEARING OR BILL. AND ANY OTHER
DESTRUCTIVE ACTS TO ADDRESS ANY
DISRUPTIVE CONTENT PRODUCT I
WILL TAKE THE FOLLOWING STEPS.
IF AN INDIVIDUAL DISRUPTS OUR
HEARING PROCESS I WILL DIRECT
THEM TO STOP AND WARNED THEM
THAT CONTINUED DISRUPTIONS MAKE
CONTENT REMOVAL FROM THE
CAPITOL BUILDING. I WILL ALSO
DOCUMENT ON THE RECORD THE
INDIVIDUAL INVOLVED IN THE
NATURE OF THE STRUCTURE OF
CONDUCT I MAY. TEMPORARILY
RECESSED THE HEARING. IF THE
CUT PONDERED DOES NOT STOP.
PRESS THE ASSISTANCE OF THE
SERGEANTS IN ESCORTING THE
BUILDING. WE HAVE TEN ITEMS ON
THE AGENDA TODAY TWO OF THOSE
ARE PROPOSED FOR CONSENT. ITEM
NUMBER ONE S. B. TWO SIX EIGHT
BY SENATOR ARCH ALETTA ITEM
FIVE SB FIVE SOME FOUR BY
SENATOR LAYERED. WE'LL HEAR
OTHER BILLS IN THE ORDER SHALL
ON THE AGENDA UNLESS OTHERWISE
NOTED WE'LL TAKE TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND TWO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION PREACH
BELL. THESE WITNESSES WILL HAVE
THREE MINUTES EACH TO PROVIDE
THEIR TESTIMONY. ALL SUBSEQUENT
WITNESSES SHOULD STATE THEIR
NAME THEIR ORGANIZATION AND THE
POSITION ON THE BILL ONLY. SEE
DO WE HAVE A QUORUM NO- OKAY-
WE WILL START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE
OUR FIRST BILL IS ITEM NUMBER.
LET'S SEE SEE WHO'S HERE. ARE
WE DON'T SEE HIM HERE WE'LL
START WITH ITEM NUMBER THREE US
SENATOR EGGMAN SP THREE THREE
THREE WOULD YOU LIKE TO JOIN US.
YOU HAVE TO DO THANKS HI I'M S.
B. AND DISTRICT BILL. I JUST
FELT THAT IT WILL UPDATE SOME
OF THE PROCUREMENT PRACTICES
RUSSELL FOR THE SAN JOAQUIN.
DISTRICT I WANT TO SAY NINE.
HEALTH SYSTEM. CHANGES TO PLACE
THANK YOU FOR- AND YOU KNOW
TIME TO TIME BERMAN- THING- AND
THERE'S A CERTAIN. NUMBER UNDER
AND FOR OURS THAT HAS BEEN
UPDATED. TWO THOUSAND FOUR.
RIGHT AHEAD OF ME COSTS AND
SENSE OF- STREAMLINING THAT
SAID SPENT UNDER THEIR ARE.
THAT I HAVE JOSH- SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF SAN JOAQUIN REGIONAL
TRANSIT. THANK YOU ALL WE
PLEASE THE- YOUR PROVIDE-
MISTER SHAW WAS HERE BECAUSE HE
ME IF I DIDN'T LOOK UP SO. NO
WORRIES HYDATID MENTION AND
MEMBERS SHAW WE SHAW YODER IN
EACH AND- REALLY PROUD TO
REPRESENT THE SANDLOT REGIONAL
JUST ARE BORED WITH TO SAY
SENATOR EGGMAN FOR CARING THIS
BILL AS WELL AS THANK AS
SIMILAR VEHICLE BLAH FOR CARTER
IN THE BILL AS YOU HEARD WE'RE
TRYING TO MODERNIZE OUR
PROCUREMENT STANDARDS IN LINE
WITH OTHER PUBLIC AGENCIES LIKE
OUR TRANSIT DISTRICT ANOTHER
TRANSIT DISTRICTS WOULD BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS BUT
THANK THE CHAIR IN HER
CONSULTANT FOR WORKING WITH US
ON THE BILL. THANK YOU RIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ARE THERE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. OKAY THERE'S NONE
HERE THE GALLERY- OKAY WE WILL
GO TO THE OPERATOR. A PLEASE OF
IF THERE'S ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT AND OR OPPOSITION. TAKE
THOSE OLD ONES TODAY. IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION- SB THREE THREE
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE AT THE
END ZERO AT THIS TIME.
CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE.
WE'LL HAVE TO WAIT UNTIL WE- I
WOULD HAVE A- CORMIER OBVIOUSLY
YOU WILL HAVE A FIRST AND A
SECOND ON THIS BILL- IF YOU
HAVE ANY A CLOSING STATEMENT.
THIS THINKING VERY MUCH FOR
HERE THIS BILL TODAY AND-
ALLOWING LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO DO
ITS JOB AND KEEP THE BUSES
ROLLING ON TIME. WELL THANK YOU
SENATOR EGGMAN HAND PALM THIS
IS IMPORTANT BUT I REALIZE IN
HIS BID THRESHOLDS ARE SO LOW
YOU CAN'T DO A LOT BUT- I THINK
PUTTING HIM. OF THAT WORK IN
PARITY WITH THE FED SO- THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING IT INTO
ACCEPTING A COMMITTEE-
AMENDMENTS WITHOUT ON WILL BE
VOTING ON. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATION- YEAH NEVER MIND.
WE'LL SEE AN ADDRESS. IT WAS A
GOOD WARM UP THINKING I KNOW
THE- YOU'RE WELCOME. OKAY WELL
WE'LL JUST SIT ON THAT ONE FOR
AWHILE OUR NEXT WILL HAVE ITEM
NUMBER TWO SB THIRTEEN SENATOR
DODD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- S. B.
THIRTEEN WILL EXTEND THE SUNSET
OF A PILOT PROGRAM IN NAPA AND
SAN BERNARDINO COUNTIES
ALLOWING LOCAL AGENCY FORMATION
COMMISSION SLAPPED GOES TO
AUTHORIZE CITY OR DISTRICT
SERVICE OUTSIDE URBAN
BOUNDARIES. I'LL BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS SUGGESTED THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. MY AB FOUR
OH TWO FROM TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN- ESTABLISHED A PILOT
PROGRAM IN THAT BUT SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTIES ALLOWING A
LOT GO TO AUTHORIZE CITY OR
DISTRICT TO PROVIDE SERVICES
OUTSIDE ITS- BOUNDARIES IT'S
FEARFUL IT'S TO SERVE. EXISTING
OR PLANNED USE LAND USES AS
LONG AS THE EXTENSION WILL NOT
ADVERSELY IMPACT AGRICULTURE
OPEN SPACE. GIVEN THE PUBLIC
BENEFITS AFFORDED BY THE PILOT
PROGRAM IN BOTH COUNTIES AND
THE LIKELIHOOD THAT THESE
COUNTIES WILL AGAIN REQUIRE THE
FLEXIBILITY AFFORDED BY THE
PILOT PROGRAM. IT'S APPROPRIATE
TO EXTEND THE PROVISIONS OF AB
FOUR OH TWO UNTIL JANUARY FIRST
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY SIX.
ADDITIONALLY S. B. THIRTEEN
ADDS A LIMITED- AUTHORIZATION
FOR LAP DAPPLE LAUGH GO TO
ALLOW SEWER EXTENSION BY THE
CITY OF SEEN ALINA WHAT THE
PURPOSES OF BRING IMPORTANT.
ENVIRONMENTAL AND HOUSING
BENEFITS INCLUDING SERVING FARM
WORKER HOUSING. APART APPROVAL
FOR NAPOL LAUGH GO THE SEWER
EXTENSION WOULD WE SERVE FUTURE
FARM WORKER HOUSING UNITS IN
THE REDEVELOPMENT OF FORMER
MOBILE HOME PARK IT TOO
AVAILABLE SHORT TERM RENTAL
HOUSING UNITS. LOCAL CONTROLS
PRESERVED AS A CITY COUNTY IN
LIFE GO WOULD ALL NEED TO
APPROVE THESE PROJECTS. ON THE
PHONE TODAY IN SUPPORT IS
SUPERVISOR DIANE DILLON ON
BEHALF OF NAPA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND NAPA LASKO
THANK YOU. VERY MUCH- MYSTERY
OF US USE ME OPERATOR CAN WE
PLEASE GET THE SUPERVISOR DYLAN
ON THE LINE. THANK YOU HAVE
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THIS IS
BRIAN DILLON NAPA COUNTY
SUPERVISOR- CHAIR MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
NAPA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND THE NAPOLI
LOCAL AGENCY FORMATION
COMMISSION THAT BELASCO WE'RE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN AND WOULD LIKE TO
THANK SENATOR DOCTORS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE. THERE
ARE TWO REASONS FOR THE COUNTY
AND NAPA LAUGHTER STRONG
SUPPORT FIRST WE HAVE LONG
STANDING LAND USE ORDINANCES TO
HELP PREVENT URBAN SPRAWL AND
PROTECT NATURAL RESOURCES BY
DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
INCREASE THE BUILDING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN NINETEEN
SIXTY EIGHT FIFTY THREE YEARS
AGO WE ESTABLISHED THE FIRST
AGRICULTURAL PRESERVE SPENDING
DESTINATION IN THE UNITED
STATES. SPEND FAN NAPA COUNTY
HAS CONTINUOUSLY BEEN GUIDED BY
TWO COMPLEMENTARY PRINCIPAL.
AGRICULTURAL LAND SHOULD BE
PROTECTED. DEVELOPMENT SHOULD
OCCUR AND URBAN AREAS ALSO
KNOWN AS CITY CENTER GROWTH.
THIS PILOT PROGRAM WOULD NOT
DISTURB THOSE GUIDING CANNOT
AND IN FACT WOULD REINFORCE
THEM AND THAT'S BECAUSE OUR
SECOND ESSENTIAL REASON FOR
SUPPORTING SB THIRTEEN RELATES
TO HOW IT CAN HELP PROPERTY
OWNERS AND THE AGRICULTURAL
THEN. CREATE MORE AGRICULTURAL
EMPLOYEE HOUSING DISTRICT
PURSUANT TO HEALTH AND SAFETY
CODE SECTION ONE SEVEN ZERO TWO
ONE POINT EIGHT THE COST OF
BUILDING SIX HOUSING INCLUDE
ADEQUATE WELL WATER AND SEPTIC
SYSTEM IF YOU'RE OUT ON
AGRICULTURAL LAND REDUCING
THESE COSTS BY MAKING THE
POSSIBILITY OF ACCESSING PUBLIC
WATER AND SEWER SYSTEM. WILL
ADD AN INCENTIVE TO BUILD AND-
NOT MAKE THE PLANS HAVE TO COME
INTO THE FAIR EMPLOYMENT TO GET
ANNEXED SO IT'S LIKE A SELF
DEFEATING- SITUATION AND
DEFEATS THE PURPOSE THAT THE
AG'S MOUNTING. SO FOR ALL THESE
REASONS WERE VERY PROUD NAPA
COUNTY AND NAPA LASKO TO
SUPPORT SB THIRTEEN AND THANK
SENATOR DODD VERY MUCH FOR
OFFERING IMPORTANT LEGISLATION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SUPERVISOR LET'S MOVE ON TO ARE
THERE ANY OTHER- WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT. THIRTY ONE HERE IN THE
ON A TWO C. NONE. LET'S MOVE ON
TO HAVE AN OFFICE PAMELA MILLER
FROM CAL LEFT CO. OPERATOR WE
COULD SPEAK TO MISS MILLER.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
PAMELA MILLER AND I'M
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL AGENCY
FORMATION COMMISSION. GALLAGHER
HAS TAKEN AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION ON SB THIRTEEN
BASED ON THE APRIL TWENTY NINTH
AMENDMENT. I WANT TO BEGIN BY
THANKING SENATOR DODD AND HIS
STAFF AND YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF
AND CHAIR FOR WORKING WITH US.
AS WELL AS WITH NAFTA AND CAME
IN AND YOU KNOW LAST CODES ON
THE BILL. I ACTUALLY WORKED
WITH THE SENATOR IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN CRAFTING EIGHTY FOUR OH
TWO WHICH CREATED THE PILOT
PROGRAM. A TELESCOPE DOES NOT
OPPOSE THE PROGRAM I WANT TO BE
REALLY CLEAR ABOUT THAT WE DO
NOT OPPOSE THAT- GRANT. IN ITS
ORIGINAL FORM NO DO NOR DO WE
OPPOSE IT BEING EXTENDED FOR
ANOTHER FIVE YEARS. THAT'S
NOTED AND THE ANALYSIS AND IN
BOTH LAST COACH REPORTS TO THE
LEGISLATURE. ARE UTILIZING THE
PROGRAM FOR ITS ORIGINAL
INTENDED PURPOSE. UNFORTUNATELY
THERE RECENT AMENDMENT ADDING
FIVE SIX ONE THREE THREE POINT
SIX TO THE SPECIFIC BENEFITTED
THINK CLEAN IS WHAT QALAAT CODE
DOES NOT THE COURT AND WE ARE
REQUESTING ITS REMOVAL. H. AS
IN ELEPHANT DUNG BY YOUR STAFF
POINTS OUT THE CAREFULLY
CRAFTED PILOT PROGRAM
ESTABLISHED IN EIGHTY FOUR OH
TWO ONE POINT EIGHT TO ALLOW
EXTENSION OF SERVICE. EXISTING
OR PLANNED USES THAT WERE
INCLUDED IN A GENERAL OR
SPECIFIC PLANS AS OF JULY FIRST
TWENTY FIFTEEN WHICH IS
EXPLICITLY. DEFINED IN THE
CURRENT STATUTE. THE OF THIS.
ACTS A- THE REQUIREMENT OF
EXISTING OR PLANNED USE. THEIR
BY POTENTIALLY ALLOWING
APPROVAL OF THE EXTENSION OF
SERVICE FOR NEW USES AND NEW
DEVELOPMENT- AND SO IF WE
UNDERSTAND THE CITY OF FRANKLIN
AS A FULL COULD FARMWORKERS
HOUSING AND REDEVELOPMENT OF A
MOBILE HOME PARK AT MAIN COULD
SHORT TERM RENTALS. THE FACT
THAT THERE IS STILL SOME
QUESTION AND DISPUTE ABOUT
WHETHER THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
SITE IS CONSIDERED NEW OR
EXISTING- IN FIFTEEN HAS REYES
A THREE. TERM FOR US. WE
BELIEVE THAT IF IN FACT THE
PARCELS NOTED AND FIVE SIX ONE
THREE THREE POINT SIX ARE
INCLUDED IN A PRESS SPECIFIC
PLAN AFTER. SEVEN ONE FIFTEEN
THE MAP ALASKA CANADA AT THE
APPLICATIONS FOR EXTENSION OF
SERVICE FOR THOSE PERSONAL.
WITHIN THE EXISTING LANGUAGE.
THE NEW SUBSECTION WE BELIEVE
CREATES A DANGEROUS PRECEDENT
FOR PROVING EXTENSION SERVICE.
AID IN THE DEVELOPMENT PROCESS
OF NEW USERS OUTSIDE THE CITY'S
JURISDICTION. WHICH IS NOT
ALIGNED WITH THE INTENT OF
EXISTING OR PLANNED YOU. AND
FURTHER IT CREATES A CONFLICT
WITHIN THE STATUTE ITSELF IN
TERMS OF LAUGHTER MISSION OF
ENSURING EARLY GROWTH AND
DEVELOPMENT. AROUND POTENTIAL
APPROVAL OF SUCH AN EXTENSION
OF SERVICE TO PARCEL. FOR WHICH
SPECIFICALLY IT HAS YET TO BE
IDENTIFIED- ON WHICH NEW
DEVELOPMENT OR NEW UNITS WILL
OCCUR IT'S NOT IN THE SPIRIT
FOR WHICH THE PILOT PROGRAMS IN
EIGHTY FOUR OH TWO WITH THE
DALLAS. AGAIN I WANT TO BE
CLEAR WE DON'T OPPOSE THE
EXTENSION OF THE PILOT PROGRAM
FOR ANOTHER FIVE YEARS. IN ITS
ORIGINAL FORM AND INTENSELY
USED BY BOTH NAPA AND SAMPOERNA
DINO LASKO. AND WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTING THE
REMOVAL OF SUBSECTION FIVE SIX
ONE THREE THREE POINT SIX FOR
THE REASONS I'VE SHARED THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISS MILLER- IF YOU DON'T
MIND- SENATOR CAN REESTABLISH A
CORPSMAN. BEFORE THANK YOU.
SECOND I WE ARE HERE
AGUIAR-CURRY PRESS LAST HERE
LACKEY PRESS BLOW BLOW PRESS
BERNHARDT. REMEMBER BY
PRESIDENT OF ROBERT WHILE MOST
PRESS BUSH. THREE OF US
PRESIDENT ROBERT REED.
ROBERT RIVAS PRESIDENT. YOU
HAVE SEVEN ZERO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND WE HAVE THAT OKAY-
WILL CONTINUE WITH THE OPERATOR
OPERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE- WE
HAVE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT FOR
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
JUST YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION.
IF YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF S. B.
THIRTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OPERATOR- OTHER ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE FROM
THE COMMITTEE. WE HAVE A- WE
HAVE A MOTION FROM HOMELESSNESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMON AND HIS
SECOND FIVE BOERNER HORVATH.
THAT'S WHY TAKEN TWO YEARS TO
GET THE RUN. MMHM GOOD LUCK TO
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE OKAY WELL- CENTER DODD- I.
REALLY APPRECIATE WORKING WITH
THE COMMITTEE ON THE AMENDMENTS
ALTHOUGH CAL LEFT WHO DOES
RAISE SOME FAIR POINTS I
UNDERSTAND THE NEED FOR
CREATIVE SOLUTIONS TO BUILD
HOUSING WAS PART IN YOUR BILL
TODAY THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL AGUIAR-CURRY HI
AGUIAR-CURRY I. LACKEY. LACKEY
I BLOOM FLOW AYE
BOERNER HORVATH-
BOERNER HORVATH HI ROBLES RAMOS
I WAS RIVAS WHOSE RIVERSIDE
ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS I YOU
HAVE SEVEN ZERO OKAY WE HAVE
SEVEN ZERO ONE- SENATOR AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR JOINING
US TODAY THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS APPRECIATED THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO TO NUMBER
ITEM NUMBER FOUR S. B. THREE
FORCE HUESO WELCOME. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- COMMITTEE MEMBERS-
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT SB SEVEN THIRTY FOUR
TODAY THE SIX TO PROTECT THE
FISCAL SOLVENCY OF CALIFORNIA
CITIES BY ALLOWING THEM THE
OPPORTUNITY TO RE NEGOTIATE
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNTS OF DEBT
ACCRUED THROUGH THE
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES SOME
CITIES IN OUR IN OUR STATES
STILL HAVE. DEBTS THAT THEY'VE
BEEN ACCRUED MANY OF THOSE
ENTERED INTO PARTNERSHIPS WITH
COUNTIES AND AGREEMENTS WITH
COUNTIES TO IN MANY CASES
SOMETIMES FUNNEL MONEY INTO-
COUNTIES AND CITIES THROUGH-
CREATIVE FINANCING SCHEMES
HOWEVER. MANY OF THEM- JUST
VERY PLAINLY HAD AGREEMENTS.
THAT COULD BE RENEGOTIATED
THERE'S- SOME- SPECULATION OR
AT LEAST SOME OPINIONS THAT
BELIEVE THAT THIS LEGISLATION
IS REQUIRED TO ALLOW. COUNTIES
AND CITIES SOME THAT ARE WE
WILLING TO DO THAT WILLINGLY TO
GO INTO AGREEMENTS THE QUESTION
IS WHETHER THEY ARE. LEGALLY
ALLOWED TO DO THAT AND TO THE
CURSED PRINCESS- CITY LAWS. SO
WITHOUT THIS BILL THE REQUIRED
STATUTORY AUTHORITY IS ABSENT
AND COUNTIES ARE HINDERED IN
THEIR ABILITY TO RESTRUCTURE OR
PROVIDE RELIEF FROM EXORBITANT
EXORBITANTTHAT TO
MUNICIPALITIES SOMETIMES
EXTENDING THE REPAYMENT DATE OR
SOMETIMES- RICK RE- ORGANIZING
THE WAY THE DEBT IS PAID THIS
COULD BE ACCOMPLISHED. IF OTHER
THIS BILLWOULD ALLOW IT SO- IN
IN EIGHT NINETEEN AN EXAMPLE OF
THIS- THAT MEANT. I HOPE CAN
BE- PROVIDE SHED SOME LIGHT
INTO WY WE NEED THIS BILL IN
NINETEEN NINETY THE CITY OF
HUNTINGTON PARK LOS ANGELES
COUNTY NEGOTIATED A PASSED
THROUGH AGREEMENT WITH THE
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES AND
CONSOLIDATED FIRE PROTECTION
DISTRICT IN IN THE- OF LOS
ANGELES COUNTY. UNDER THIS
AGREEMENT FORTY EIGHT POINT 9%
OF THE RTA'S REVENUE PASSED
THROUGH THE COUNTY. AND FIFTEEN
POINT 5% TO THE FIRE PROTECTION
DISTRICT. BACK THEN THAT WAS
LEGAL AND BACK THEN AND
CURRENTLY IS STILL- COVERED
UNDER THE- THE ORIGINAL
CONTRACT. THE R. D. A. USE THE
REMAINING 35% OF THE FUNDS WHEN
RDAS WERE DEFENDED DISBANDED BY
THE COURTS. OF COURSE THIS PUT
AN ONEROUS- WAIT ON THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO REPAY OR TO
CONTINUE TO PAY THAT CONTRACT
SO- DOES CITY OF HUNTINGTON
PARK IS REACHING RESELL TIGHTLY
COUNTY AND THEY'VE BEEN.
CONTEMPLATING A RESTRUCTURING
BUT UNDER THE CURRENT STATE
LAWS THEY BELIEVE THAT THAT
WOULD NOT BE ALLOWED SO THIS
WOULD SIMPLY ALLOW. CITIES AND
COUNTIES TO SIT AT THE TABLE
DOESN'T REQUIRE THEM TO IT
DOESN'T INSTRUCT THEM TO IT
DOESN'T MAKE THIS PROCESS IN
ANY WAY MANDATORY IS JUST
SIMPLY. A PROCESS THAT ALLOWS
CITIES AND COUNTIES TO SIT AT
THE TABLE SHOULD THEY CHOOSE TO
DO THAT AND RENEGOTIATE SHOULD
THEY CHOOSE TO DO THAT THIS LAW
WOULD JUST SIMPLY MAKE IT
EASIER FOR PEOPLE TO SAVE
TAXPAYER DOLLARS AND TO HELP. A
CITIES- BALANCE THEIR BUDGETS
EVERY SINGLE YEAR I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NIVAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
LET'S MOVE ON YOU HAVE I
BELIEVE TWO PEOPLE IN SUPPORT
ARNOLD ALTURAS LAWSON FROM CITY
OF HUNTINGTON PARK ON THE PHONE
AND STEVE CARMONA OF THE CITY
PICO RIVERA ON THE PHONE.
OPERATOR. ARNOLD IS NOT I DO
NOT SEE STEVE YET. WE CAN START
WITH MR GLASSMAN. YES THAT
THANKS VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE-
MY NAME IS ARNOLD ALBERS
GLASSMAN I AM THE CITY ATTORNEY
FOR THE CITY OF HUNTINGTON PARK
THANK YOU FOR LISTENING TO OUR
POSITION TODAY IN THE TWENTY
TWELVE ACTIONS TAKEN WHICH
RESULTED IN THE- LAMINATION OF
PRE DEVELOPMENT AGENCIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. HOWEVER SUCH ACTION
HAD A DETRIMENTAL IMPACT UPON
MANY CITIES WHO HAVE EXISTING
PAT FACT THE PASTOR WILL BRING
ITS- AND IMPORTANTLY. A KEY
SOURCE OF REVENUE FOR
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES TO REPAY
THE OBLIGATIONS INCURRED BY
THOSE PASSED THROUGH YOUR
CREMINS. THE DIRECT IMPACT OF
THE ELIMINATION OF
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES HAS
RESULTED IN MANY CITIES BEING
LEFT WITH THE GOVERNMENT
OBLIGATIONS. CITY OF HUNTINGTON
PARK WHO SUPPORT THIS BILL IS
AN EXAMPLE OF COMMITTEES JUST
LIKE YOURS. WHO UNDER S. B.
SEVEN THIRTY FOUR WILL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO NEGOTIATE A
METHOD OF ACHIEVING FINANCIAL
RELIEF FROM THE SIGNIFICANTLY
HIGH INTEREST RATES ESTABLISHED
IN THE PAST REMAINS WILL ALSO
ALLOW THE POSSIBLE REDUCTION OF
PRINCIPAL ALL THE- BY THE
FORMER REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES.
AND ALLOW CITIES AND COUNTIES
TO REACH- TO RESULT IN THOSE
NEGOTIATIONS. SB SEVEN THIRTY
FOUR PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR RELIEF AND RECOVERY.
CURRENTLY UNDER THE PASTOR
AGREEMENT NINETEEN PARK I NEED
TO MARCOS THAT PRACTICALLY TWO
HUNDRED SIXTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
INTO THE HIGH RATE OF INTEREST
RATES. THESE NUMBERS WILL
CONTINUE TO SKYROCKET. SB SEVEN
THIRTY FOUR PROVIDES A
MECHANISM FOR LEVEL FIELD
NEGOTIATIONS TO REDUCE THOSE
AMOUNTS BY UP 225% INTRODUCTION
INTEREST RATES FROM THE RANGE
OF 7% OR MORE DOWN TO ZERO. SB
SEVEN THIRTY FOUR IT IS
IMPORTANT TO MAINTAIN THE
FINANCIAL STABILITY JUST STOP
CITIES AND TO PROTECT THOSE WHO
PAY THEIR TAXES DURING THIS
DIFFICULT TIMES. WE BELIEVE
THAT SB SEVEN THIRTY FOUR IS A
BALANCED APPROACH IS A GOOD
START AND A MUCH NEEDED COURSE
OF ACTION TO ADDRESS THE
SIGNIFICANT OBLIGATIONS A
FORMER REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES
TWO HUNDRED THESE PASSED
THROUGH REMATCH. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME TODAY AND WE
RESPECTFULLY URGE AND I BOTH
FOR SB SEVEN THIRTY FOUR THANK-YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH- IS
MISTER CARMONA ON THE LINE YET.
I DO NOT THINK I'M DOUBTING
YET. THAT'S AT. HELLO THIS IS
ANGELINA GARCIA REPRESENTING
STEPHEN CARMONA FOR THE CITY OF
PEORIA VERA OKAY THANK YOU.
WELCOME. THANK YOU I APOLOGIZE-
THANK YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON AS
I SAID I AM AND THAT DIRECTOR
OF ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES HERE
AT THE CITY OF CALGARY VARIANT
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY FOR
INSTRUCTABLE RIGHT AS THE
LEGISLATION IS CRITICAL IN
PROTECTING OUR FISCAL POLICY AS
WELL AS ALL THE OTHER
CALIFORNIA CITIES BY PROVIDING
US THE OPPORTUNITY TO
RENEGOTIATE- THE SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT THAT WE- TODAY COUNTY
INTERNET- WITH RESPECT TO SEE-
PASTOR AGREEMENT. WE'VE OVER
THE YEARS ENTERED INTO SEVERAL
PATH TO AGREEMENT WITH THE
COUNTY OF ALLEGHENY AND WE
CURRENTLY OWE ABOUT FORTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS WITH NEARLY ONE
THIRD REPRESENTING INTEREST. I
AN UNDERPRIVILEGED COMMUNITY
WOULD LIKE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
MODIFY THE INTEREST RATE ON THE
STAT FROM OUR CURRENT DEBT DOWN
TO ZERO. BUT WILL IT AFFECT 25%
OF THE PRINCIPAL AMOUNT OF
OUTSTANDING DEFERRED PASS
THROUGH PAYMENTS OWED. BY THE
FORMER RDA AND THE- AGENCY TO
ATTACK TO THAT TAXING ENTITY.
IN ADDITION THE BILL WOULD
PROVIDE RELIEF CAST AN
UNDERPRIVILEGED COMMUNITY THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ALSO RENEGOTIATE
PLEDGE PROPERTY TAXES SALES
TAXES. AND ANY OTHER- REVENUE
SOURCES AT TOWARDS REPAYMENT OF
THE COMPOUNDING AND DECADES OLD
DEFERRED OBLIGATIONS. THIS WILL
ALLOW US TO STRUCTURE THE
EXISTING OBLIGATION IN AN
EQUITABLE WAY AND ENSURE THAT
WE CAN- YOU KNOW. GIVE YOU
ATTENTION TO THE INVESTMENT IN
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT IN THE
CITY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT.
SB SEVEN THIRTY FOUR. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- ARE THERE ANY OTHER
ANYONE ELSE HERE IN THE.
GALLERY AND PART OF THE BILL.
ALL RIGHT THAT'S FINE OUT WE
HAVE ANYWHERE AT ALL. SEEING
NONE HERE IN THE GALLERY NOR DO
WE HAVE ANYONE LISTED OPERATOR.
SO PLEASE BRING THROUGH IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO S. B. SEVEN
THIRTY FOUR PLEASE. IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF ACTS BE SEVEN
THIRTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
OPERATOR LETS US OTHER ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE- WOULD ENTERTAIN A
MOTION. OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION
BY BURKE BOERNER HORVATH AND
THE SECOND BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BLOW- WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU JUST SIMPLY-
APPRECIATE- THE STAFF WORK ON
THIS BILL AND- APPRECIATE THE
CHAIR AND ALL OF YOU- I
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ASK FOR. AN AYE
VOTE. THANK. YOU SO MUCH FOR
BRING THIS FOR BECAUSE I'VE
ALWAYS LOOK FOR DO TO HELP OUT
OUR CITY. AND OUR LOCAL- AND
DISK TO RE OF THE DAY- WITH A
PARTNER. I'M REALLY TO SEE THIS
TODAY AND- WE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS IN THE HOUSE COMMITTEE
DEVELOP COMMITTEE. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AGUIAR-CURRY LINE AGUIAR-CURRY
LACKEY. LACKEY I BLOOM BLOOM
I'M BOERNER HORVATH FOR I ROLES
RIGHT RAMOS SIDE THREE OF US.
THREE OF US I ROBERT REED.
WEBER OKAY. WILL TELL HI EIGHT
ZERO. EIGHT YOUR BILLS NOTHING
YOU THANK YOU MUCH SINCE HER
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT AFTERNOON
OKAY ALL THOSE WHO DISTRICT
MORE NO. I WILL GO TO THE
JUMPED IN I DON'T KNOW EIGHT SB
FOUR SO SIX SENATOR MEN.
RUSSIAN PROCEED MENTOR YES
PLEASE DO. SO MUCH IN THE
ASSEMBLY THANK YOU SO MUCH NICE
TO MEET SOME OF YOU FOR THE
FIRST TIME NICE TO SEE OTHERS-
MANAGER I SINCERELY APPRECIATE
THE TIME AND THOUGHTFUL
DIALOGUE THAT YOU AND I'VE HAD
AND THAT OUR STAFF HAVE HAD IN
CONSULTATION ON THIS BILL-
UNFORTUNATELY I AM NOT
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS
PROPOSED IN THE CAMINO SIS AND
I WANNA EXPLAIN WHY- IS- YOU
WE'VE TRIED TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION REPEATEDLY ON THIS
BILL. ARE FUNDAMENTALLY WE'RE A
DIFFERENT POSITION- I BELIEVE
MY STAFF POLICE AND OUR
SPONSORS BELIEVE. THAT THE PACE
PROGRAM IS RIFE WITH FRAUD THAT
IS SOMETHING THAT NEEDS REFORM.
THAT WE SEE TOO MUCH IN BEAUCE
AND THAT THE FRAMERS AND SENATE
AND INCENTIVES BUILT INTO THE
PACE PROGRAM. ARE FUNDAMENTALLY
FLAWED PUTTING VULNERABLE
HOMEOWNERS INCLUDING LOW INCOME
HOMEOWNERS ELDERLY AND
MINORITIES AT RISK. ARE THE
OPPOSITION IT DOES NOT BELIEVE
THAT AND SO THIS GETS TO THE
CRUX OF OUR BILL BUT I BELIEVE
THE AUDIT THAT WE PROPOSE AND
SOMETHING THAT WE I WILL
DISCUSS. HAVE REPEATEDLY TRIED
TO SCALE DOWN- IT'S SOMETHING
THAT'S CRITICAL TO ADDRESSING
THE ABUSES WE ARE SEEING IN
PACE FINANCING. A LOT HAS BEEN
DONE TO IMPROVE CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS IN CASE BUT THE
CURRENT MODEL ALLOWS FOR
PRACTICES WE KNOW ARE HARMFUL
TO CONSUMERS. DOOR TO DOOR
SALES SAME DAY CONTRACTS NO
INDEPENDENT ASSESSMENT OF
PROPOSED UPGRADES NO
VERIFICATION OF WORK BEING
COMPLETED BEFORE PAYMENTS ARE
PROCESSED. PAGE CONTRACTORS WHO
GENERALLY HAVE NO FINANCIAL
TRAINING. IT'S HOMEOWNERS IT'S
COMPLICATED FINANCIAL PRODUCT
AND HAVE A PERVASIVE INCENTIVE
TO UP SELL. THE CURRENT
REGULATORY STRUCTURE DOES NOT
ADEQUATELY DISRUPT THIS
INCENTIVE. INSTEAD OF MAKING
CLEAR TO HOMEOWNERS THAT PACE
FINANCING WILL PACE PLACE A
SUPER PRIORITY LIEN ON THEIR
HOME CONTRACTORS TYPICALLY AND
TOO OFTEN PITCH PACE AS A
GOVERNMENT APPROVED PROGRAM.
THAT REQUIRES NO MONEY DOWN.
THE KEY SELLING POINT MADE TO
CONSUMERS IS THAT PACE FINANCED
HOME IMPROVEMENTS WILL PAY FOR
THEMSELVES THROUGH ENERGY COST
SAVINGS. SO IF THAT'S THE CASE
THAT PACE INDUSTRY SHOULD
WELCOME THE ACCOUNTABILITY OF
AN UP FRONT SCALED DOWN ENERGY
ASSESSMENT. UNFORTUNATELY WE
KNOW THIS BUSINESS MODEL WE'VE
HEARD COUNTLESS STORIES OF
FRAUD ABUSE AND WHILE SOME OF
YOU HAVE ASKED FOR DATA WE
DON'T HAVE THAT IT'S NOT
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE WE DO KNOW
THAT CONSUMER ADVOCATES
INCLUDING THE ONES THAT YOU'LL
HEAR FROM. I HAVE REPEATEDLY
TOLD US THAT THIS IS ONE OF THE
TOP AREAS OF CONSUMER FRAUD
THAT THEY HEAR ABOUT. HOMEOWNER
PROMISED ENERGY SAVINGS THAT
MAY NEVER MATERIALIZE. AND
POTATO PATCH UPGRADES THEY MAY
NOT NEED AND THEN LEFT ON THE
HOOK. AFTER THE CONTRACTORS AND
ADMINISTRATORS HAVE MADE THEIR
PROFITS. SB FOUR SEVENTY SIX
WOULD ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM HEAD
ON BY REQUIRING A QUALIFIED
THIRD PARTY TO PERFORM AN
ENERGY AUDIT TO ENSURE THE
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE HOME WILL
REDUCE ENERGY CONSUMPTION. AND
FOSSIL FUELS USE. A HOME ENERGY
ASSESSMENT ARMS TO HOMEOWNERS
WITH VALUABLE INFORMATION ABOUT
THE ENERGY USE IN THEIR HOME
THE APPROPRIATENESS OF THE
IMPROVEMENTS THEY ABOUT TO
UNDERTAKE FOR THEIR HOUSEHOLD.
ENERGY AUDITS ARE COMMON AND
REQUIRED FOR OTHER ENERGY
EFFICIENCY PROGRAMS INCLUDING
CPUC SINGLE FAMILY AFFORDABLE
SOLAR HOMES PROGRAM. AND ENERGY
SAVINGS ASSISTANCE PROGRAM AS
WELL AS IN THE COMMERCIAL PACE
PROGRAM. NOW WE IN RESPONSE TO
SOME OF THE CONCERNS WE HEARD
ABOUT THIS AUDIT REQUIREMENT
HAVE NARROWED THIS AUDIT
REQUIREMENT PRETTY
SIGNIFICANTLY- THE CURRENT
VERSION THE BILL CLARIFIES-
THAT. THE WHO CAN PERFORM THE
AUDIT IS GOING TO BE VERY
EXPANDED AND WE SCALE DOWN THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR THAT. WE'VE
NARROWED THE SCOPE OF THE
ENERGY AUDIT BY REALLY ONLY
REQUIRING AN ASSESSMENT OF THE
PARTICULAR HOME IMPROVEMENTS
BEING MADE- TO BE ASSESSED FOR
SUITABILITY. AND WE ALLOWED A
WAIVER OF THE AUDIT FOR
EMERGENCY HOME IMPROVEMENTS
THIS IS REALLY A SUITABILITY
TESTS THAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR.
UNDER THE CURRENT TEXT OF SB
FOUR SEVENTY SIX
CONSERVATIVELY- WE EXPECT THAT
THERE OVER FIFTEEN HUNDRED
QUALIFIED THIRD PARTY HOME
ENERGY AUDITORS AND STATE. AND
AT THE COST OF ENTRY FOR NEW
AUDITORS WOULD BE VERY LOW. NOW
YOU MAY HEAR FROM OPPONENTS OF
THE L. YOU MAY HAVE HEARD FROM
OPPONENTS OF THE BILL. THAT
HOME ENERGY AUDITS CAN COST UP
TO SIXTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS OR
MORE. AND THAT IS SIMPLY NOT
TRUE OF A TYPICAL INTERVIEW
WHAT IT WOULD BE A HARD A
COUPLE HUNDRED DOLLARS. BUT AS
BEFORE SEVENTY SIX IS A
REQUIREMENT. BECAUSE IT'S JUST
BEEN NARROWED THE SUITABILITY
REVIEW OF THE PROPOSED HOME
IMPROVEMENTS. WILL BRING THAT
DOWN WE'RE HOPING SOMETHING
LIKE FIFTY DOLLARS OR HUNDRED
DOLLARS. SOMETHING THAT BY THE
WAY CAN BE ROLLED INTO THE PACE
FINANCING IF THE PROJECT IS
ULTIMATELY DECIDED TO BE USED
IN A PACE. FINANCING STRUCTURE.
THE SECOND IMPORTANT REFORM THE
SB FOUR SEVENTY SIX MAKES IS
HALTING PAYMENTS TO PACE
CONTRACTOR. UNTIL A PROGRAM
ADMINISTRATOR HAS OBTAINED
COPIES OF PERMITS OR FINAL
INSPECTIONS. TO VERIFY THAT ALL
WORK HAS BEEN ADEQUATELY
PERFORMED. RESIDENTIAL PACES
MANY OF YOU KNOW HAS A HISTORY
OF CONSUMER COMPLAINTS
REGARDING UNFINISHED. OR AN
ACCEPTABLE WORK AND
IMPROVEMENTS THAT CONTRACTORS
HAVE CHARGE FOR BUT NEVER
INSTALLED. WELL THE GOALS OF
PACE ARE ONES THAT ARE LAUDABLE
AND IMPORTANT ONES THAT I
SHARE. AFTER ALL WE DO WANT OUR
HOMES GETTING TO- ENERGY
EFFICIENCY IT'S IMPORTANT WAY
TO TRY TO MEET OUR- AMBITIOUS
ENERGY ZERO EMISSIONS ENERGY
MANDATES IN THE STATE. THIS
PROGRAM HAS UNFORTUNATELY BEEN
MARRED WITH CONSUMER FRAUD AND
ABUSE. THE PACE PROGRAM IS
FAILING AND EVIDENCE ABOUNDS.
THE ONLY THREE STATES AT THIS
POINT STILL USE PACE CALIFORNIA
MISSOURI AND FLORIDA. IN
CALIFORNIA L. A. COUNTY HAS
ALREADY ENDED ITS PACE PROGRAM
AFTER DETERMINING THAT THE
PROGRAM LACKED ADEQUATE
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS. THE
WESTERN RIVERSIDE COUNCIL
GOVERNMENTS IS ENDING ITS PACE
PROGRAM. AND JUST THIS MONTH
AND THE FBI MOVE TO HAVE REP
REVOKE RENOVATE AMERICA'S PACE
ADMINISTRATOR LICENSE. AFTER
HOMEOWNERS IN SAN. DIEGO COUNTY
WERE REPEATEDLY DEFRAUDED. IT'S
CLEAR TO ME THAT THE SAID QUO
IS NOT SUSTAINABLE AND EXPOSES
CALIFORNIA HOMEOWNERS TO TOO
MUCH RISK. NOW SOMEONE SAID
THAT THIS BILL WOULD
EFFECTIVELY END THE PACE
PROGRAM IN CALIFORNIA. I ARGUE
THAT IT DOES THE OPPOSITE THIS
GIVES A LIFELINE THROUGH
MEANINGFUL REFORMS. TO THIS
PROGRAM THAT RIGHT NOW IS
FAILING THE STATE WHERE WE HAVE
TO ASK SERIOUS QUESTIONS ABOUT
ITS FUTURE IN THE STATE. GIVEN
ITS DIRECTION. NOW AGAIN I
APOLOGIZE I REALLY WANTED TO
TAKE THESE AMENDMENTS AYE I
THOUGHT LONG AND HARD ABOUT
THIS. BUT I DON'T WANT THIS
BILL TO BE A SOMETHING THAT
GETS PASSED WITHOUT MEANINGFUL
CHANGES THAT WILL ACTUALLY
ADDRESS THE LEVELS OF FRAUD
THAT WERE SAYING. AND THEN
ULTIMATELY HAVE THE INDUSTRY
POINTED THIS BILL IN TWO YEARS
OR FOUR YEARS. AS A REASON WHY
WE DON'T NEED FOR THE
REGULATION I DON'T THINK THIS
BILL WITHOUT THE AUDIT GOES FAR
ENOUGH- AND SO THAT IS WHY I
RELUCTANTLY AM. ASKING FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE IN THE SITUATION. WITH
ME TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF THIS
BILL- STACEY TAUGHT FROM UC
IRVINE CONSUMER LAW CLINIC. AND
JENNIFER SPERLING FROM THE
BETSY TECH LEGAL SERVICES.
OPERATOR OPERATOR LOOKING FOR
MISS TUCKER A MIST BERMAN PLACE.
THANK YOU BOTH FIND GIRLFRIEND.
HELLO THANK YOU MY NAME IS
JENNIFER BURLINGAME A LEGAL
SERVICES ATTORNEY WITH ATHLETIC
IN LOS ANGELES I REPRESENT LOW
INCOME HOMEOWNERS AND SENIORS
AND I'M PROUD TO BE STANDING
WITH SENATOR MAN AND DEPARTING
AT THREE FOUR SEVEN SIX TODAY.
YOU FINANCING TARGET LOW INCOME
HOMEOWNERS WITH LOANS THEY
CAN'T AFFORD WHICH BECOME SUPER
PRIORITY TAX LIENS THAT PUT
THEIR HOMES AT RISK. NOTING
AGAINST ENERGY ON IT BECAUSE
THERE MIGHT BE AN UP FRONT COST
TO THE CONSUMER FUNDAMENTALLY
MISSES THE TRUTH OF WHAT A
HARMFUL COST TO A CONSUMER
REALLY IS WHEN IT COMES TO THE
PAGE PROGRAM. THIRTY SEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS THAT IS THE
COST A CLIENT WAS CHARGED. FOR
SEVENTEEN WINDOWS. TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS THAT IS THE PRICE OF
TWO DOLLARS. FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER THREE HIGH
EFFICIENCY TOILET IT LUDICROUS
TO THINK THAT AT THESE PRICES
PAGE FINANCE IT WILL CREATE A
COST SAVINGS TO THE CONSUMER BY
THE WAY NONE OF THESE PRODUCTS
WERE EVER INSTALLED BUT THE
CLIENT IS PAYING ANYWAY NINE
THOUSAND DOLLARS EVERY YEAR FOR
TWENTY YEARS FOR LITERALLY
NOTHING. A HUNDRED AND FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS YEAH I DON'T
THE COST ONE POINT OF PAYING
FOR SOMETHING CALLED HIGH
PERFORMANCE ROOFING I'M NOT
TWELVE HUNDRED SQUARE FOOT HOME
60% OF THOSE COSTS OR INTEREST
PAYMENT LINING THE POCKETS THE
PROGRAM ADMINISTRATOR WITH THE
NIGHT PRESENTED TO KICK BACK TO
THE JOINT POWERS AUTHORITY
SPONSORING THE PROGRAM. THESE
ARE NOT EXCEPTIONAL CASE THAT
ENDED COMMITTEE SHOULD
RECOGNIZE THAT IN THE PAST FEW
YEARS L. A. COUNTY LEGAL
SERVICE PROVIDERS HAVE SEEN
OVER FIVE HUNDRED VICTIMS
OVERWHELMING OUR INTAKE LINE
FOR SHOCKING STORIES THAT
SIMPLY WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO
HAPPEN IF PEACE WERE REGULATED
WITH THE SCRUTINY. OTHER
PROPERTY SECURED LOAN PRODUCTS
WE HAVE HEARD HEARTBREAKING
STORIES FROM ALL. CORNERS OF
THE STATE. RANDY FUNDAMENTALLY
NOW SIR UP PURPOSES THAT WERE
ORIGINALLY INTENDED AND THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY THROUGH AT THE
FOUR SEVENTY SIX. TO DO
SOMETHING MEANINGFUL ABOUT IT
LOW INCOME HOMEOWNERS DON'T
NEED ACCESS TO TWENTY NINE
THOUSAND DOLLARS WORTH. OF COOL
COAT PAINT. THEY DON'T NEED TO
BE SET UP FOR FAILURE WITH A
PROGRAM THAT PROVIDES NOTE
STATE GUARD THAT THE COSTLY
IMPROVEMENTS THEY ARE
UNDERTAKING WILL BE ENERGY
EFFICIENT. COST EFFECTIVE OR
INSTALLED PROPERLY WHAT THEY
NEEDED PROTECTION FROM
PREDATORY PAYDAY LOAN IF YOU
ARE GENUINELY WORRIED ABOUT
COST TO LOW INCOME CONSUMERS.
YOU WILL NOT LET THE PAID
PROGRAM CONTINUE ANOTHER MINUTE
WITHOUT AUDITS AND INSPECTIONS
TO KEEP COSTS IN CHECK TO KEEP
THE INDUSTRY PLAYERS HONEST AND
TO MAKE SURE THE WORK IS
ACTUALLY GETTING DONE. PLEASE
VOTE YES ON. SB FOUR SEVEN SIX
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE HAVE
ONE MORE SPEAKER MISTYPED
CONSUMER LAW CLINIC YEAH THANK
YOU. HI. WELL YES THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU AND
TO SENATOR MAN FOR HIS EFFORTS
ON THIS BILL I'M HERE ON BEHALF
AT UC IRVINE CONSUMER LAW
CLINIC CLIENT WHEN OUR CLINIC
STARTED I CONDUCTED A NEEDS
ASSESSMENT. A LOT OF GAP THE
ISSUE THAT REPEATEDLY CAME UP
WITH HOMEOWNERS VICTIMIZED BY
PACE. SINCE THEN OUR CLINIC HAS
BEEN OVERWHELMED AFTER THE
FIRST YEAR WE SHUT DOWN OUR
INTAKE WHICH REMAINS. CHINESE
COMPLEX FRAUDULENT TRANSACTION.
SB FOUR SEVEN SIX CAN PREVENT
THAT BY ENSURING HOMEOWNERS
HAVE CRUCIAL INFORMATION TO A
BATH AND EFFECTIVE ENERGY
EFFICIENT IMPROVEMENTS. AS OUR
CLIENTS ARE ALL LOW TO MODERATE
INCOME WE WANT TO ENSURE A FAIR
AND EQUAL ACCESS TO CREDIT AND
FIRMLY BELIEVE A SMALL UP FRONT
INVESTMENT AND AN ENERGY AUDIT
WILL PAY DIVIDENDS. AND ENERGY
AUDIT WHICH IS ALREADY REQUIRED
BY MANY OTHER GREEN FINANCING
PRODUCT OFFERED BY FANNIE MAE
FHA FREDDIE MAC AND EVEN
COMMERCIAL PACE. THE OPPOSITION
HAD WRONGFULLY ASSUMED
HOMEOWNERS WILL BE OVER
BURDENED BUT THE BILL DOES NOT
INDICATE WELL THERE THE COST IT
COULD BE COVERED BY THE PROGRAM
ADMINISTRATOR OR WITH PUBLIC
FUNDING AS SACRAMENTO DOES FOR
THE COMMERCIAL PACE PROGRAM.
ALSO OF IMPORTANCE IS THE
REQUIREMENT TO ENSURE WORK IS
COMPLETE AND CONNECT AT OUR
CLINIC IS CURRENTLY HANDLING
THREE PAID CASES IN WHICH THE
SOLAR PANELS WERE NOT CONNECTED
BEFORE THE MONEY WAS RELEASED.
NOW YEARS LATER TWO OF THE
THREE HOMEOWNER STILL DO NOT
HAVE OPERATIONAL SOLAR PANELS.
A SIMPLE UP FRONT INVESTMENT IN
AN ENERGY AUDIT WOULD HAVE ALSO
ST SEVENTY FOUR YEAR OLD ALMOST
FOSTER FROM ENTERING INTO AN
AFFECT MY CONTRACT. TOTALING
OVER A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS OF WHICH
ALMOST NINETY TWO THOUSAND MORE
THAN HALF ITS INTERESTS AND
FEES. MYTHBUSTERS NOW IMMINENT
RISK OF FORECLOSURE THE PAGE
PROGRAM COULD ABSORB THE COST
OF AN ENERGY AUDIT TO PREVENT
FAMILIES WHO LIKE MISBAH TURF
FROM LOSING THEIR FAMILY'S
GENERATIONAL HOMES. THE REST OF
THE NATION IS NOW LOOKING TO
CALIFORNIA TO REFORM THIS
PROGRAM AND TO REMAIN THE
LEADER IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF
GREEN ENERGY FINANCING. IF THIS
BILL DOES NOT PASS THE PAGE
WILL CONTINUE TO HARM
HOUSEHOLDS AND UNDERMINE THE
NATION'S TRUST AND FUTURE GREEN.
ENERGY EFFORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- WELL LET'S GO TO
THE WITH. IN OFFICE. WE HAVE
TO- MISS CRISTINA SOTO. AND
AMOS CLAUDIA MARTINEZ. BOTH
LANES ARE OPEN. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS CHRISTINE AND I'M A
RETIRED PROPERTY OWNER IN THE
SACRAMENTO AREA WHO DOES
SUPPORT CASE TODAY I URGE YOU
TO PLEASE VOTE NO ON SB FOUR
SEVEN SIX UNLESS IT IS AMENDED
TO REMOVE THE AUDIT MANDATE.
WHEN MY FAMILY WAS LOOKING TO
MAKE UPGRADES TO OUR HOME WE
EXPLORED A NUMBER OF OPTIONS TO
ADD VALUE TO YOUR HOME AND TO
DEAL WITH THE SUMMER HEAT AFTER
GOING THROUGH THE LIST OF
OPTIONS WE FELT THAT WHITE
GREEN AND PAYS FOR THE BEST
CHOICE FOR US FOR EXAMPLE WE
WERE ABLE TO INSTALL LARGE
PATIO SHADE STRUCTURE THAT
COLDER HOME. LOWERING OUR
ENERGY BILL WE ALSO INSTALLED
NEW HIGH HIGH EFFICIENCY JERK
AND IRRIGATION SYSTEM IN OUR
YARDS SAVING PRECIOUS WATER AND
LOWERING OUR WATER BILL AS WELL
SH IF I HAD THE PAPER AND ITS
ENERGY AUDIT UP FRONT THIS
WOULD HAVE BEEN AN ADDED COST
AND WOULD HAVE BEEN CONFUSING
TO DETERMINE WHAT I NEEDED TO
COMPLETE COMPARED TO THE LIST
OF THINGS HE OUGHT IT WOULD
SUGGEST. THIS WOULD HAVE
CHANGED MYMIND AND MADE PAYS
LESS APPEALING FOR MY FAMILY IN
FACT AND MOST IMPORTANTLY I
WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
RETIRE WITHOUT USING PACE AND
WOULD HAVE HAD TO WORK LONGER
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN
ORDER. TO MAKE THESE PROPERTY
UPGRADES. WHY EXPLAINED THE
TEAM WOULD WORK. AND HOW I CAN
MAKE UPGRADE WITH NO MIND MONEY
DOWN. I WAS SO EXCITED AND
HAPPY WITH WHY GRANT PASTE
BECAUSE IT MADE OUR PROJECT
AFFORDABLE. THE BEST PART WAS I
DID NOT HAVE TO PAY ANY MONEY
OUT OF POCKET. WHICH ALLOWED ME
TO AVOID TAPPING INTO MY
PRECIOUS RETIREMENT SAVINGS.
ROGIC WENT PRECISELY AS
DESCRIBED WHICH ALSO HELP
PRESERVE OUR RETIREMENT
SAVINGS. I OPPOSE SB FOUR SEVEN
SIX AS DRAFTED BECAUSE LIKE ME.
THERE ARE OTHER FAMILY OWNERS
WHO WOULD LIKE TO MAKE UPGRADES
TO THEIR HOME. AND PASTE COULD
BE THEIR MOST COST EFFECTIVE
OPTION. FORCING HOMEOWNERS TO
PAY FOR AN ENERGY AUDIT OUT OF
POCKET IS NOTHING MORE THAN
ATTACK. THAT WOULD MAKE IT MORE
DIFFICULT TO HELP PROPERTY
OWNERS LIKE MYSELF. MAKE THEIR
HOME SAFER AND MORE EFFICIENT.
PLEASE VOTE NO ON SB FOUR SEVEN
SIX UNLESS THE AUDIT MANDATE IS
REMOVED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE HAVE ONE
MORE SPEAKER IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE. THANK YOU AND GOOD
AFTERNOON- MY NAME IS CONNIE
MARTINEZ MY REPRESENTS THE L.
A. METRO HISPANIC CHAMBER. OUR
POSITION IS THAT WE OPPOSE SB
FOUR FROM SIX AND ONCE IT IS
AMENDED. SPELLING METRO CHAMBER
HAVE AN ACTIVE MEMBERSHIP OF
OVER THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED LATINO
BUSINESS OWNERS AND LOS ANGELES.
OTHER CHAMBER SUPPORTS PAY
FINANCING BECAUSE IT EXPANDS
EQUITABLE ACCESS TO CLEAN
ENERGY AND RESILIENCE UPGRADES
FOR WORKING FAMILIES THAT WISH
TO IMPROVE THE EFFICIENCY AND
SECURITY OF THEIR HOME. WE
BELIEVE THAT AMENDING AT THREE
FOUR SEVEN SIX. WHAT CHANGES
WILL PRESERVE THE PURPOSE OF
PROTECTING CONSUMERS WITHOUT
ELIMINATING PACE AS A FINANCING
OPTION FOR CALIFORNIA
BACKGROUND. I WANTED TO WORK
WITH THAT THE RECORD STRAIGHT
ON A FEW OF THE ITEMS. THERE
ARE VERY FEW PIECE. OF PROPERTY
TAX DELINQUENCY CALIFORNIA
STUDIES HAVE SHOWN PIECE OF THE
QUINCY METRICS ARE LOWER THAN
GENERAL AGGREGATE AND SINGLE
FAMILY PROPERTY DELINQUENCY
LEVELS. WELL L. A. COUNTY DID
AND IT'S COUNTY RUN PEACE
PROGRAM. NEED TO BE IN DEMAND
BY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WHO HAS AS
RECENTLY AS LAST MONTH CONTINUE
TALKING PEACE INTO THEIR
COMMUNITIES BECAUSE IT SERVES A
VITAL COMMUNITY NEED. AND THAT
THE FLP CALIFORNIA- CONTRACTORS
STATE LICENSING BOARDS TWENTY
TWENTY ANNUAL REPORT. OUR DATA
SHOWS ONLY TWENTY FIVE P.
SPECIFIC COMPLAINT TO THE MEDIA
ART DEPARTMENT OF THIS BUSINESS
OVERSIGHT. FOR REFERENCE FIFTY
S. I'LL BE RECEIVED OVER
SEVENTEEN THOUSAND COMPLAINT.
OUR PRIMARY CONCERN IS ENERGY
AUDIT REQUIREMENTS IN THE
APARTMENT EVEN THOUGH SOME
AMENDMENTS HAVE BEEN MADE TO
REDUCE THE SCALE OF THE
MANDATORY AUDIT PERFORMED. AND
EXPAND THE NUMBER OF CERTIFIED
AUDITOR THANK YOU PERFORM THE
AUDIT WE STILL HAVE CONCERNS
WITH THIS BILL AS CURRENTLY
WRITTEN. THE REALITY IS THAT
THERE ARE A LIMITED
AVAILABILITY OF CERTIFIED
ENERGY AUDITOR. AND THEIR
AUDITS ARE EXTREMELY COSTLY THE
ENERGY AUDIT MANDATE WILL
CAUSE. PROJECT DELAYS WHICH
WILL INCREASE THE COST TO THE
CONSUMER FAMILIES WE HAVE TO
WAIT WEEKS OR LONGER TO
SCHEDULE AN ENERGY AND ENERGY
AUDIT. PERFORMED THE AUDIT
CAUSING SIGNIFICANT DELAYS IN
THE PROJECT. MANDATORY ENERGY
AUDITS ARE JUST SIMPLY BAD
PUBLIC POLICY- FURNITURE
INDUSTRY GATHERS THE PERSON
OVER TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
THOUSAND HOME IMPROVEMENTS
ELEVEN FINANCED FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS HAVE BEEN INVESTED IN
BENEFICIAL IMPROVEMENTS FOR
COMMUNITIES. I REDUCE FIVE
MILLION METRIC TONS OF
GREENHOUSE GASES. OVER TEN
BILLION GALLONS OF WATER HAVE
BEEN SAVED. AND TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF LOCAL JOBS HAVE
BEEN CREATED WE UNDERSTAND THE
OTHER PROVISION IS INTENDED TO
EDUCATE HOMEOWNERS. ABOUT WHICH
EXPENDITURES ARE PRUDENT AND TO
PROTECT AGAINST CONTRACTORS UP
SELLING MEASURES THAT ARE
EITHER TO BE OR TOO EXPENSIVE
FOR A HOME TEN SECONDS. WE
CONTINUE TO. SHE TEN SECONDS
PLEASE. WHAT THE THING THAT WE
DO SHARE YOUR GOAL OF
PROTECTING CONSUMERS AND WE ARE
COMMITTED TO POLICY SOLUTIONS
THAT ARE SUSTAINABLE AND VIABLE
FOR THE LONG TERM HEALTH OF
CALIFORNIA AND ALL OF OUR
CITIZENS SO WE HOPE THAT YOU
ALSO OPPOSE ABOUT US. NOT
BEFORE SHOOTING AT THE FOUR
SEVENTY SIX THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME NO THANK YOU VERY FOR YOUR
TIME WE APPRECIATE IT- OPERATOR
WE PLEASE OPEN THE LINES FOR-
FOR S. B. FOUR SEVEN SIX
OPPOSITION AND SUPPORT PLEASE.
THANK IF YOU WISH SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OR- SB FOUR SEVEN SIX.
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND I CURRENTLY HAVE
ABOUT FIFTEEN LINES IN Q. OR
TRYING TO TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CLAUDIA POLSKY DIRECTOR
UC BERKELEY ENVIRONMENTAL LAW
CLINIC I'M CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR SEVEN SIX
THANK YOU. RIGHT TO TACKLE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE HELLO
CHAIR AND MEMBERS DANIELLE
COUNTERPARTS ARE ON BEHALF OF
THE CO SPONSORS OF THIS BILL TO
CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME CONSUMER
COALITION AND THE NATIONAL
CONSUMER LAW CENTER
CALIFORNIA'S URGENTLY NEED THIS
BILL WE URGE YOU TO PASS IT-TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
pYOUR ORGANIZATION AND YOU'RE A
POSITION ON THE BILL. TRYING TO
FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THAT IN TURN MEMBERS KEVIN GOLD
WITH CALIFORNIA BANKERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOUR SEVEN SIX THANK YOU. RIGHT
TO FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WRECKING INSURED MEMBERS INTO
REPAIRING THE PUBLIC LAWCENTER
INSTRUCT THE PLAN AT THE BILL.
THANK YOU. TRYING TO SIXTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
AND WELCOME TO CONSOLIDATE THE
PUBLIC LAWCENTER AT STRONG
SUPPORT SB FORCE. THANK YOU.
THANK CHIU FORTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI I AM LONELY WALKER
WENT OUT ALONE ADVOCACY AND I'M
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT AND
I'VE BE FORTHCOMING SIX THANK
YOU THANK YOU. BY JUNE FIFTY
THREE PLEASE CALL HAVE. STONE
STONE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SOLAR AND STORAGE
ASSOCIATION WITH THE CLOSE AND
LEFT A MINUTE IS AN
AFTERTHOUGHT IT PROVISIONS.
THANK YOU. RIGHT TO FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
ANNA BACK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. FIND YOUR SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
JUSTUS TRONG WITH WIDE GREEN
ENERGY FUND ARE POSITIONED AS
OPPOSED TO COMPLY CEMENT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ALL TO PLEASE
CALL I HAD. HELLO MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS THIS IS COLIN BISHOP
WITH PACE NATION ARE PUT OUR
POSITION IS OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED TO REMOVE THE AUDIT
REQUIREMENTS THANK YOU. TRYING
TO THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS DARYL ALL
RIGHT NINE VICTIM OF THE HERO
IF- GRAHAM OKAY MORE THAN
EIGHTY THOUSAND DOLLARS- TOOLS.
TO ENGINE FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS KRISTOFF
LEBEL WITH SPOKANE VALLEY
LEADERSHIP GROUP WE RESPECT WE
HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION AND LINE WITH THE
REASONS OUTLINED IN A LETTER.
SUBMITTED TO THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU BY TWO THIRTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
CHRIS PETERSEN THE REPRESENTS
FORTY FIVE FINANCIAL
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED TO REMOVE AUDIT
PROVISION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
EMILY YOU TELLEM HAPPENED A
CALIFORNIA CREDIT UNIQUE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. WHY TO
FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BUYING TWO ONE FOUR. THIS IS
MEGAN VIEWS ON BEHALF OF PUBLIC
COUNCIL IN CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE S. B. FOUR SEVEN
SIX. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS ANDREA JACKSON I AM
CALLING OF THE HOMEOWNER WHO
WAS HARMED BY FAITH I AM STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR SEVENTY SIX
THANK YOU. NINE TO FIFTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MY
NAME IS RACHEL CALLED AND I'M
CALLING FROM PAY FUNDING GROUP
WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED TO REMOVE THE ORDER
PROVISION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
BY TWO FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MARGARET CLANCY HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE NEW FINANCIAL
MORTGAGE FINANCE- IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL WE HAVE AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED MUST THE AUDIT
PROVISIONS YOU MET THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WHETHER ANY QUESTIONS OF
THE COMMITTEE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
THANK YOU CENTER FOR BRING THIS
FORWARD AND HELPING ME
UNDERSTAND A NEW ASPECT THE
PLACE THAT I DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT
BEFOREHAND- I HAD A COUPLE
QUESTIONS SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION OF TALKED ABOUT THE
FACT THAT- THE PIECE AUDIT IS
NOT NOT CANNOT BE BUNDLED AND-
THEM SORRY THE EFFICIENCY AUDIT
CANNOT BE BUNDLED INTO THE PACE
FINANCING YOU SAY IT IS COULD
YOU EXPLAIN THAT AND THE SECOND
QUESTION IS AROUND THE EQUITY
ISSUE IN THE HOW WILL LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS BE ABLE TO
AFFORD THE ON IT I KNOW YOU'RE
TRYING TO MAKE IT MORE
AFFORDABLE YET BUT IF IT CAN'T
BE BUNDLED IN. TO ANY SORT OF
FINANCING HOW DO WE ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIANS OF ALL INCOME
LEVELS CAN ACCESS THE FUNDING I
APPRECIATE THE QUESTIONS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND- MY STRONG
UNDERSTANDING I'M HAPPIER FOR
THIS TO MY WITNESSES HERE IS
THAT THE- AUDIT OR THIS IS
SUITABILITY AUDIT CAN BE ROLLED
INTO THE FINANCING SO THE MAIN
QUESTION IS WHAT YOU DO IF THE
CONSUMER THE HOUSEHOLD DECIDES
NOT TO PROCEED WITH PACE
FINANCING- AND OF COURSE THAT
DOES PRESENT OBSTACLE NOW WE
WANT TO MAKE CLEAR WE HAVE NOT
SAID THE CONSUMER HAS TO PAY
FOR THIS. WE BELIEVE THAT- IT
COULD BE THE PUBLIC FINANCING
AND MANY CITIES HAVE ADOPTED
PROGRAMS LIKE THIS AS WAS
MENTIONED IN ONE OF THE
WITNESSES TESTIMONIES I COULD
BE THE CONTRACTOR THEMSELVES IT
COULD BE THE PACE PROGRAM OKAY
MISTER- WE'RE TALKING ABOUT I
ONLY CLEAR WHAT WE ENVISION
HERE IS A STRIPPED DOWN
SUITABILITY STANDARD AND WE
HAVE MADE NUMEROUS AMENDMENTS
I'M WE DONE THAT WITHOUT ANY
FEEDBACK FROM- INDUSTRY BECAUSE
THEY HAVE REFUSED TO WORK WITH
US ON THIS AT ALL AND SO- WE
HAVE MADE ALL THESE AMENDMENTS
ON OUR OWN TRYING TO MAKE THIS
A BETTER BILL- WE ACTUALLY
OFFERED AT ONE POINT WE WERE
STILL WILLING TO CONSIDER THIS.
ESSENTIALLY A PRO FORMA SOLAR
CHECK SO THAT IT WOULD JUST BE
SOMETHING WITH WE KNOW THE
NUMBER OF SOLAR PANELS WE KNOW
HOW MUCH EFFICIENCY WE CAN LOOK
AT SOME OF THE ELECTRIC BILL
AND SEE IF IT'S SUITABLE FOR
THEM WITHOUT EVEN HAVING
SOMEONE COME TO YOUR HOME BUT
AGAIN WE HAD NO RESPONSE TO
THESE- REPEATED- ENTREATIES TO
THE OTHER SIDE. BUT OUR GOAL
HERE IS TO MAKE THIS LIKE A
FIFTY DOLLAR OUR- ENERGY. FOR
MOST TYPE OF PROJECTS OR LESS-
WE ENVISION A WIDE POOL OF
AUDITORS- AND OF COURSE I AGAIN
I'M I'M- FAIRLY CLEAR THIS IS
SOMETHING WE- ASK FOR THE VERY
OUTSET. I ASKED PERSONALLY
ABOUT. CAN THIS BE ROLLED UP IN
THE FINANCING I WAS TOLD
ABSOLUTELY YES BY LET'S
COUNCIL. I WAS TOLD YES BY OUR
SPONSORS BUT I'D LIKE TO REFER
THIS QUESTION- TO MY WITNESSES-
SO JENNIFER OR STACY IF EITHER
OF YOU COULD TAKE THAT ON I'D
APPRECIATE IT. YES AND THIS IS
STACEY TACTIC IN AND TO TAKE
THAT ISSUE ON- I WOULD STATE
THAT I DO BELIEVE THAT
FINANCING COULD BE SET UP IN
SUCH A WAY THAT THE COST FOR
THE ENERGY AUDIT COULD BE
ROLLED INTO THE FINANCING. AT
ORIGINATION IN FACT THE PLANS
THAT DO REQUIRE ENERGY AUDITS
FOR RESIDENTIAL PAY FINANCING
ALREADY HAVE THIS FEATURE THAT
INCLUDES WITH FANNIE MAE
FREDDIE MAC FHA. IN COMMERCIAL
PACE AND SO GIVEN THE FACT THAT
IT HAS BEEN ACHIEVED WITHIN
THOSE AREAS PROGRAM WE THINK
THAT THAT CAN ALSO BE ACHIEVED
HERE WITHIN THAT TRANSACTION.
IN ADDITION TO THAT WE REALLY
DO HAVE TO LOOK AT THE COST
BEING AVOIDED BY THE HOMEOWNERS
WHO ARE UP SOLD INSTEAD MORE
EXPENSE. IMPROVEMENT THAN WHAT
THE ENERGY AUDIT REVEALED THOSE
IMPROVEMENTS WOULD ACTUALLY
GAIN FOR THEM THAT'S THE VALUE
OF THE AUDIT IS TO ENSURE THAT
IF A LOW INCOME HOMEOWNER IS
TAKING ON DEBT. IN ORDER TO
FINANCE ENERGY EFFICIENT
PRODUCTS THAT IN THE END OF
THOSE PRODUCTS ARE GOING TO PAY
FROM THEMSELVES AND THEY'RE
GOING TO SEE THAT SAVINGS IN
THEIR UTILITY BILLS. ENSURING
THAT THE FINANCING IS ACTUALLY
AFFORDABLE FOR THEM AND. WILL
NOT RESULT IN THE LOSS IS THAT.
DURABLE. BUT IT IS A CRISIS-
SORRY JUST SAY FINE FINE- SO
WHAT THAT THAT DOES A LEVY
EIGHT SOME OF MY CONCERNS I
THINK THAT NEEDS TO BE MORE
EXPLICIT IT'S NOT VERY
COMFORTING TO BE HERE AND THE
OTHER HOUSING HERE WE BELIEVE
IT WILL LEAD WHAT WE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO HEAR IS IT WILL BE
RIGHT NOT WE BELIEVE THAT ARE
YOU KNOW. WELL TO FAR FOR THAT
I KNOW YOU HAVE ANOTHER
COMMITTEE TO GO AND- I HAVE TO
BE HONEST I WAS NOT GOING TO
VOTE FOR THIS BILL YESTERDAY
AND THEN I GOT A TEXT FROM MY
SISTER THAT EXACTLY THE FRAUD
YOU'RE TRYING TO ADDRESS THAT
THIS BILL. WAS HAPPENING TO MY
MOTHER WELL SO- I THINK IT IS
MORE PREVALENT THAN WE THINK
AND I THINK WE HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT THIS OF SELLING
TO A SEVENTY EIGHT YEAR OLD
WOMAN WHO IS FIT BUT MAYBE YOU
KNOW AS- YOU KNOW MAKING
DIFFERENT CALCULATIONS IS. AS
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF SOME PEOPLE
WHO SHOULD NOT BE TAKEN
ADVANTAGE OF FOR THE PURPOSE OF
I THINK WHAT WE WANT WITH THE
ENERGY EFFICIENCY- THAT PAYS
PROVIDE SO WITH THAT I WILL
MOVE THE BILL SO IT CAN BE
CONSIDERED FURTHER COMMITTEE
BUT I DO RESERVE THE RIGHT TO
VOTE ON THE FLOOR IF WE CAN'T
TAKE CARE OF THESE ISSUES AND
HOW SOME CERTAINTY THAT. YOU
KNOW WE'RE NOT ACTUALLY. MAKING
IT UNAFFORDABLE FOR PEOPLE. I
APPRECIATE THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AND I. IF THIS BILL DOESN'T
VATICAN ME YOU HAVE MY WORD
THAT WE WILL MAKE THAT EXPLICIT
MY WAS TOLD. MILEAGE COUNCIL
THAT IT ALREADY IS ROLLED UP
AND I THINK. THAT THE WITNESS
TUTS TESTIMONY WAS THAT IN
OTHER ENERGY AUDIT PROGRAMS- IT
ALREADY IS ROLLED UP AND SO- I
BELIEVE HAS ALWAYS BEEN IT. IT
WILL BE THAT WAS THE INTENT OF
THE BILL AND IF IT'S NOT CLEAR
RIGHT NOW I AM HAPPY TO MAKE
THAT CHANGE. HI MISS RIVAS.
SUMMARY THIS. THANK YOU FOR
PRESENTING THIS SPELL- HE WAS.
AS YOU NOTED IN YOUR TESTIMONY
THAT. LAST YEAR L. A. COUNTY
ENDED ITS PACE PROGRAM. BECAUSE
OF THE FRAUD I HAVE MANY
CONSTITUENTS. THAT HAVE. GONE
THROUGH THAT. AS A RESULT OF.
OF AND TRAIN A PACE. AGREEMENT
WITH AN ADMINISTRATOR- AND BUT-
I'M NOT SURE. IF REQUIRED AN
AUDIT. WELL OF WELL WE'LL
CHANGE THAT I GUESS AND YOU
KNOW WILL THAT IS THAT THE
RIGHT SOLUTION RIGHT AND AN
AUDIT THAT IN MY FOR MY
CONSTITUENTS THAT ARE- MAJORITY
LOW INCOME THAT THEY HAVE TO
PAY FOR SO IT'S AN ADDITIONAL
COST TO THE HOMEOWNER- AND WHAT
IS THIS AUDIT IS THIS. IS THE
HOMEOWNER NOW GOING TO NOW SAY
NO TO THE CONTRACTOR BECAUSE OF
THIS AUDIT HOWEVER WE ASSURING
THAT. THIS IS GOING TO WIN FOR
BETTER INFORM THE HOMEOWNER I
APPRECIATE THE QUESTION- AND
JUST AGAIN AS FAR AS HOW WE
ENVISION YOU GOT IT IT'S REALLY
KIND OF A SUITABILITY STANDARD
RIGHT WE LOOK AT THE DIFFERENT
MOVING PARTS OF YOU KNOW
SOMEBODY THAT THIS IS NOT MEANT
TO SOLVE THE PROBLEM OF I THINK
ONE OF THE OPPOSITION WITNESSES
WHO KNEW THAT SHE WANTED PAY
SHE DONE HER OWN RESEARCH THIS
IS MEANT TO ADDRESS THE PROBLEM
OF THE COLD CALL TO THE
GRANDMOTHER THAT CONTRACTORS
WALKING DOOR TO DOOR. AND
HITTING PEOPLE UP AND
MISLEADING THEM AS TO WHAT THIS
IS ABOUT AND THE PROBLEM OF
COURSE IS THAT PACE IS NOT A
NORMAL FINANCING PROGRAM IT
CREATES A SUPER SENIOR LEAN
BACON CALLS FORECLOSURE OR
OTHER PROBLEMS RIGHT IF YOU
DON'T PAY IT CREATES ALL SORTS
ATTENTION AND BECAUSE IT HAS
THE GOVERNMENT'S IMPRIMATUR
BEHIND IT IT IS MARKETED AS A
GOVERNMENT PROGRAM I AND IT'S
BEEN RIFE WITH ABUSE I GUESS
THE CASE I'D MAKE IS THAT ONE
I'D BE HAPPY TO EXPLORE PUBLIC-
FUNDING FOR THIS I THINK THERE
ARE ALREADY. PROGRAMS THAT DO
THIS UTILITIES DO THIS CITIES
DO THIS I I'M TOLD THAT PC MAY
HAVE FUNDS THAT WE CAN ALLOCATE
TOWARDS THIS PURPOSE BUT ALSO I
GUESS IF WE'RE THINKING ABOUT
THIS THIS WAY WHAT IS FIFTY
DOLLARS OR SO IN THE CONTEXT OF
A SEVERAL THOUSAND DOLLAR
PROJECT WHEN IT'S ROLLED UP ALL
TOGETHER WHEN YOU AMORTIZE THAT
OVER THE LIFETIME OF THE CASE
ALONE I THINK THAT GIVEN THE
SCALE OF FRAUD WERE SAYING YOU
KNOW TALKING ABOUT PENNIES PER
MONTH RIGHT. BUT TO GIVE US
COMFORT THAT THIS IS PREVENTING
THE TYPES OF FRAUD THAT WE'RE
SEEING I WOULDN'T PROPOSED THIS
IF THIS PROGRAM WAS PRISTINE.
AND WE YOU KNOW EVERYBODY WITH
HAD THE EXPERIENCE OF THE ONE
OPPOSITION WHEN. THE PROBLEM IS
THAT WE'RE SO TO PEOPLE GET THE
FRIED AND YOU HEARD- ONE OF MY
WITNESSES SAY. THAT THIS IS THE
MOST COMMON THING THEY'RE
SAYING THAT THEIR BACKLOG WITH
COMPLAINTS THIS IS A REAL ISSUE
WE DON'T HAVE HARD NUMBERS ON
HOW MANY. WE JUST KNOW THAT
IT'S OVERWHELMING CONSUMER
ADVOCATES. AND IT'S ONE OF THE
REASONS I DECIDED TO TAKE THIS
ON AS A FRESHMAN. NOT
NECESSARILY REALIZING HOW
INTENSE THE POLITICS AROUND
THIS WOULD BE- BUT BUT I THINK
THIS IS A RIGHTEOUS BILL I
THINK THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
CREATE SOMETHING THAT PROVIDE A
MEANINGFUL CHECK. UP FRONT.
THAT SAYS OKAY IS THIS AN
APPROPRIATE PROJECT FOR YOU.
FOR YOUR LEVEL FINANCES- FORGET
WHAT YOUR ELECTRIC BILL IS WILL
IT PROVIDE ENERGY AND
TREATMENTS WILL SAVE YOU MONEY
AT THE END OF THE DAY. AND
THESE ARE ALL WORTHWHILE GOALS
IN THE CONTEXT OF THE TYPES OF
FRAUD WERE SAYING. AND
ALTERNATELY I BELIEVE THIS WILL
SAVE ON AVERAGE THE AVERAGE
CONSUMER MONEY IT MAY COST. THE
OPPOSITION WITNESS A FEW
PENNIES A MONTH IF YOU WILL SET
UP IN THE PACE. BUT IT WILL
SAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE THE
HEARTACHE OF HAVING THE STRESS
THE TENSION OF THE BEING
DEFRAUDED. BY THE MANY
SCAMSTERS THAT ARE OUT THERE
UNFORTUNATELY. I'M SO AGAIN I'M
HAPPY TO WORK PERFECT AS I
WOULD EMPHASIZE THAT WE'VE BEEN
KIND OF WORKING THROUGH THIS ON
OUR OWN BECAUSE- INDUSTRY HAS
NOT WORKED WITH US ON THIS
AUDIT THEY'VE TAKEN A HARD
POSITION FROM THERE TO VERY
BEGINNING. THAT THEY WILL NOT
ACCEPT ANY OUT OF ANY KIND NO
MATTER HOW MUCH WE TRY TO
TAILOR THIS TO JUST BE AS
MINIMAL A BURDEN AS POSSIBLE.
BUT I DO BELIEVE THERE IS A
REAL PROBLEM IN THIS INDUSTRY-
AND THAT AN AUDIT ALONG WITH
THE BACK AND HOME INSPECTION
PRONG THAT WE'RE REQUIRING THIS
BILL AS WELL. WILL HELP MAKE
MEANINGFUL PROGRESS. TO
CRACKING DOWN ON THE FRONT OR
SING. I AGREE WITH YOU. IF YOU
KNOW THE AUDIT IF YOU HAVE MORE
DETAILS ON HOW THE AUDIT THE-
COST. ME KEEP SAYING FIFTY
DOLLARS BUT- I'M NOT. SURE
WHERE THAT NUMBER IS COMING
FROM. IT'S MIKE MY HEAD INFO
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO WIN YEAH
YOU ENVISION THAT I THINK OUT
FIFTY DOLLARS. SEEMS VERY
REASONABLE. BUT I'M NOT SURE.
WELL I DON'T HAVE ANY DATA THAT
SHOWS HOW MUCH. WHAT IS THE
TRUE COST OF THESE AUDIBLES. I
LIVE IN A RURAL COUNTY YEAH-
AND SOMEONE HAS TO COME FROM.
TWO HOURS AWAY. UP TO PERFORM
AN AUDIT YEAH. HOW MUCH IS THAT
GOING TO BE IS IT REALLY ONLY
GOING TO BE FIFTY DOLLARS. YEAH
I THINK IT WOULD BE DIFFERENT
IF THERE WERE STATE PROGRAM.
YEAH THAT. YOU KNOW THE COPAY
FOR THE HOMEOWNER WAS ONLY
FIFTY DOLLARS. AND SO. THAT TO
ME ISN'T CLEAR UP THIS BILL IF
IT WORK. I WOULD BE WILLING TO
SUPPORT IT- BECAUSE THAT'S-
YOUR WHOLE. THE SOLUTION RIGHT.
TO PREVENT TEEN IT'S HAPPENED
MORE FRAUD YEAH. AND YOU KNOW I
KNOW THAT UTILITIES AND OTHERS
MAYBE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE
THESE. AUDIT PROGRAMS. I KNOW
THERE ARE THEIR COMMONALITY
COUNTY. AND SOME OF THE
UTILITIES THAT GO OUT TO YOUR
HOME. USUALLY IT'S FREE. TO ALL
ESPECIALLY TO A LOW INCOME.
CONSUMER I KNOW MY MOM WHEN
SHE- HAD HER OWN HOME. THERE
WAS AN AUDITOR THAT CAME OUT
AND MADE SUGGESTIONS FOR ENERGY
EFFICIENCY AT HER HOME. IT WAS
COMPLETELY FREE TO HER. YEAH
AND- BUT IN THIS CASE WE DON'T
KNOW THE COST TO THE- HOMEOWNER
I THINK THAT. IT COULD BE
CREATING MAY BE MORE FRONT END
UP. IN THAT INDUSTRY AND I
DON'T KNOW MUCH ABOUT IT. AND
SINCE. THE DETAILS OF. THAT
PART OF YOUR BILL. ARE CLEARER.
AND I KNOW YOU HAVE A VISION.
WELL BUT ARE YOU WILLING TO
WORK MAKE THIS INTO YOUR BILL
TO CONTINUE WORKING ON THAT
VISION AND- MAKING IT MORE OF A
REALITY. IN THE BILL WITH WEEKS
OF. SORRY YEAH. TO INTERRUPT.
THE FIRST RESPOND ON I GUESS
I'D SAY IT FOR- WE HAVE DATA
POINTS AS THE FIFTY INCOME OUT
OF NOWHERE OUT WHICH IS IT A
HOME RIGHT NOW COSTS IN MOST
REGIONS BETWEEN FOUR HUNDRED
EIGHT HUNDRED THAT'S EVEN TRUE
HIGH COST AREAS LIKE MIKE
ORANGE COUNTY LOS ANGELES SAN
FRANCISCO- THE OPPOSITION
STATED FIGURE SIXTEEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS WAS SOMETHING THAT I
SEEM TO COME I KIND OF COME OUT
OF THE GOLD STANDARD OF A VERY
RARE TYPES OF ENERGY AUDITS.
ACCORDING TO VARIETY OF
CONSUMER WEBSITES HOME ENERGY
AUDITS TYPICALLY COST BETWEEN
TWO HUNDRED TO SEVEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS ON AVERAGE THAT'S THE
SOUP TO NUTS BUT AGAIN WHAT WE
HAVE ARTICULATED OUR BILL IS
THAT THIS IS PROJECT SPECIFICS
ARE NOT LOOKING AT EVERY WINDOW
EVERY YOU KNOW AIR CONDITIONING
SYSTEM WE'RE LOOKING AT WHAT
THE CONTRACTORS PROPOSING WAYS
TO BE A SUBCONTRACTOR COMES
YOUR HOUSE AND SAYS WE WANT TO
DO- SOLAR PANELS WHICH IS THE
MOST COMMON TYPE OF HOME
IMPROVEMENT. WE WOULD ONLY LOOK
AT THAT- AND I DO BELIEVE AND
WE ALSO LOWERED THE STANDARDS
FOR WHAT THE REQUIREMENTS FOR A
ENTERED ENERGY AUDITOR OF THIS
TYPE NEEDS NEEDS TO HAVE TO BE
ABLE TO DO THIS SO ACCORDING
AND I'M HAPPY TO REFER THIS
MIGHT MIGHT WITNESSES BECAUSE
THEY HAVE MORE DETAILS BUT- WE
ESTIMATE THAT WE'RE GONNA HAVE
A LOT MORE PEOPLE THAT ARE
ELIGIBLE TO DO THESE ARTISTS
YOU WON'T HAVE PEOPLE DRIVING
FROM TWO HOURS AWAY EVEN IN THE
RURAL COUNTIES- IN THE INLAND
COUNTIES. THAT WE WILL HAVE A
LOT MORE ELIGIBLE PEOPLE TO DO
THIS TYPE OF SCALE DOWN ENERGY
AUDIT AGAIN AS I MENTIONED I AM
HAPPY TO CONSIDER AMENDMENTS TO
DO A PRO FORMA SOLAR ASSESSMENT
SO THAT THAT IS YOU KNOW NOT
EVEN REQUIRING IT NECESSARILY
IN IN PERSON INSPECTION WE HAVE
AN OPEN TO THESE TYPES OF
CHANGES- WE DO BELIEVE THAT'LL
DRIVE THE COST DOWN FROM THAT
TWO HUNDRED DOLLAR LEVEL TO
SOMETHING BELOW THAT I CAN'T
TELL YOU WITH ANY CERTAINTY
WHAT THAT'LL BE. BECAUSE THIS
IS MARKET FORCES AT PLAY RIGHT
SUPPLYING DEMAND PRETTY SIMPLE
CONCEPT SO THAT I WOULD LOVE TO
TURN IT OVER TO- ONE OF MY
WITNESSES TO HELP ARTICULATE- A
BETTER ANSWER FOR THIS-
JENNIFER. OR STATION IF YOU
HAVE A RESPONSE. I'M YES THIS
IS STACEY TODD- AGAIN SPEAKING
ADDS TO AND KIND OF THE
AVAILABILITY AND- HOME ENERGY
RATERS AND SO HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WE DO HAVE A AT HERS
RATERS AND THEY'RE ACTUALLY AND
HAD THEIR PROVIDERS TO ASK FOR
THAT TRAINING AND AUTHORIZATION
OF THAT IS ACTUALLY ALREADY
OVERSEEN BY THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION- THERE'S A
HANDBOOK INTO A MANUAL THAT
SPECIFICALLY OUTLINE EXACTLY
WHAT THE AUDITED TO CHEAT.
ANOTHER THING THAT WE HAVE TO
KEEP IN MIND IS WHAT THE AUDIT
IS TRYING TO DO HERE FOR OUR
HOMEOWNERS IS THEY'RE ACTUALLY
TRYING TO SHOW THAT THE ENERGY
AUDIT ESTABLISHES THE STATE
INTO INVESTMENT RATIO IS
GREATER THAN ONE WHAT THAT
MEANS IS IN OTHER WORDS THAT
THE SAVINGS ACHIEVED BY THAT
FINANCED IMPROVEMENTS OVER THE
TERM. MUST OUTWEIGH THE COST OF
THOSE IMPROVEMENTS AND THAT
ENSURED THAT THE HOMEOWNER
DIRECTLY BENEFIT FROM THAT THE
REDUCTION IN THEIR UTILITY
COSTS AND ALSO IT ENSURES THAT
THE MORTGAGE LENDERS DO NOT
HAVE INCREASED RISK. DUE TO
THAT HE SAID STUPOR PRIORITY
LIEN STATUS IN ADDITION TO THAT
AND LOOKING AT THE AVAILABILITY
LET STATE AND THEN- OUT IN THAT
SITUATION IN WHICH A HOMEOWNER
MAY NOT MOVE FORWARD WITH- THE
ACTUAL FINANCING IN INSTEAD OF
OUT OF POCKET WERE THESE ENERGY
AUDIT. IF YOU LOOK AT THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF ENERGY AUDIT
THEY ATUALLY SHOWN TO PROVIDE
YOU WITH AND YOU COULD SAVE UP
25230% ON YOUR ENERGY BILLS
THEY MAKING EVEN SMALL CHANGES
AND SMALL AND EFFICIENCY
IMPROVEMENTS I WITHIN THE
PROPERTY WHICH IS WHY AS
SENATOR MEN MENTION. THERE ARE
ALREADY A NUMBER OF FREE OR NO
COST ENERGY AUDIT PROGRAMS THAT
ARE OUT THERE THAT WOULD BE
THEN AVAILABLE TO LOW INCOME
CONSUMERS AND THAT INCLUDES
THOSE THROUGH UTILITY AS THEY
OFFERED THAT FREE ENERGY AUDITS
THERE'S OTHER PROGRAMS WITHIN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT DO
THAT AS WELL. AND THEN IN
ADDITION TO THAT THERE HAVE
BEEN AND YOU GET THE POLITIES
THAT IS SPECIFICALLY I HAVE
REYES DOLLARS FOR ENERGY AUDIT
BECAUSE THAT INCREASES OUR
OVERALL GOALS AND ACHIEVING-
EFFICIENCY I'M AND MOST TIMES
THAT PUBLIC VETTING. THROUGH AS
TEXT ME BLOCK GRANT AND OTHER
WAY AND WE TO REDO THE COSTS. I
TO THE HOME DOING I WOULD JUST.
THIS IS ALREADY A REGULATED
INDUSTRY THAT CAN PROVIDE
SIGNIFICANT BENEFITS WHETHER OR
NOT THE HOMEOWNER GOES FORWARD
WITH THE PEACE FINANCING AND IT
REALLY SERVICES THAT CHECKED
AGAINST THE PREDATORY PRACTICES
THAT WE'VE SEEN THAT THERE IS A
SPOT ALL. HELP TO PERPETUATE
WITHIN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND SO WE DO BELIEVE AGAIN IT
CAN BE LOW COST AND THAT IT IS-
AN ESSENTIAL ASSESSMENTS TO
ENSURE THAT THESE CAPE BATMAN.
WORKABLE FOR THE LOW INCOME
HOMEOWNERS WHO MAY NEED TO
UTILIZE THEM. IF I COULD JUST
ADD ONE OTHER AND- JENNIFER BUT
THEN FOR ABOUT ABOUT IT AND
WELL I WAS LOOKING AT THE OTHER
POINT THAT I THINK THE OTHER
THING THAT THE AUDIT CAN BE A
CHECK ON AND I WOULD LEADING TO
THE TO MY COMMENT. IS A REALLY
RAMPANT- YOU KNOW PRICE GOUGING
THAT HAPPENS IN THIS PROGRAM
AND SO IF YOU'RE YOU KNOW. IN
TALKING ABOUT THAT RATIO OF THE
COST TO THE SAVINGS. YOU KNOW A
CONTRACTOR WHO CAN AT TELL YOU
SOMETHING AT THE MAXIMUM
POSSIBLE PRICE THAT THEY CAN
GET AWAY WITH THROUGH THE PAID
PROGRAM. THAT'S PROBABLY NOT
GOING TO BE ENERGY EFFICIENT
FOR THE HOMEOWNER BUT THAT
WOULDN'T CREEK INCREASED
COMPETITION AMONG CONTRACTORS
IN CURRENT ON ITS CONTRACTORS
TO GET INTO THE PROGRAM. AND
ACTUALLY GET HOMEOWNERS YOU
KNOW ACCURATE HONEST PRICING
FOR THE KINDS OF PRODUCTS THAT
THEY MIGHT ACTUALLY WANT TO GO
FORWARD WITH THAT MIGHT
ACTUALLY SAVE THEM MONEY OVER
THE LONG TERM. AFFORD FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR THREE
CLEARLY. YOU KNOW. YOU'RE NEVER
GOING TO MAKE THAT BACK BUT AT
THE SAME A DIFFERENT CONTRACTOR
MIGHT. MAKE A DIFFERENCE-
ESTIMATE FOR YOU FOR A LAUGH
THAT MIGHT BE SOMETHING THAT
YOU WOULD GO FORWARD WITH AND
YOU MIGHT USE CASE FINANCING UP
TO OBTAIN THE PRODUCT THAT AND
I HAD MORE EQUITABLE COST. IF I
COULD JUST ADD ONE QUICK POINT
ON TO THAT- WE AS I MENTIONED
WE TOOK AMENDMENTS TO LOWER THE
THRESHOLD AND TO CLARIFY WHAT
TYPE OF SCALE DOWN AUDIT WE'RE
LOOKING FOR- A AND EVEN IF
THERE WERE NO ADDITIONAL ALL.
THE PEOPLE THAT. DID THAT AT A
PLAN TO QUALIFY TO DO THESE OUT
OF. THEY'RE CURRENTLY FIFTH
HUNDRED FIFTY SAID INSPECTOR IN
THIS. GIVEN THAT THE ARE JUST
OVER TWELVE TO. PAGE PROJECTS
COMPLETED IN TWENTY NINETEEN
LAST PRE OPENED YEAR. THAT WE
SAY THAT THERE'S ONE AUDITOR
FOR EVERY NINE CASE PROJECTS
OUT THERE AND THAT'S ASSUMING
AGAIN. THAT NOBODY ELSE APPLIES
TO DO THESE TYPES OF. STRIPPED
DOWN PACE ARTISTS THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT- THERE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS YES- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ALMOST. YOU OF MADAM CHAIR AND
I THINK YOU CENTER FOR BRINGING
THIS ISSUE. I SAID ON THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND CHAIRED THE SAN
MARINO TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY
PACE PROGRAMS WAS A TOPIC WE'RE
GOING THROUGH MORE ON THE
LEAVES THAT THEY'RE PUTING ON
THE HOMES WHEN THEY TRIED TO
RESELL THOSE HOMES ARE SELDOM
HOMES. SO WE ENDED UPBY
CREATING A SUBORDINATE
SUBORDINATION CLAUSE THAT WAS
IN THERE THAT WAS ACCEPTED-
WHEN THOSE LEADS ARE PUT ON
THERE SO THAT THE HOMEOWNER
COULD CHARGE WILL MOVE FORWARD
AND THEN THE COST IT WAS OR
WASN'T THE FIRST ITEM ON THE
LEAD- AND NOW I'M LOOKING AT
WHAT'S COMING FORWARD I DO HAVE
SOME SOME CONCERNS. OVER THE
COST OF THE AUDIT THAT WOULD
COME INTO THE HOMEOWNER YOU
MENTIONED THAT THERE'S- THE
HIGH COST OF SIXTEEN HUNDRED
AND A LOW COST OF TWO HUNDRED
YES EVEN IF YOU TRY TO FIND
AVERAGE COST AIR DOESN'T EQUATE
TO THE FIFTY DOLLARS THAT YOU
TALKED ABOUT WHAT THAT YOU ALSO
TALKED ABOUT SCALING DOWN THE
AUDIT TO CERTAIN AREAS. SO MY
QUESTION IS WHEN YOU SCALE IT
DOWN TO CERTAIN AREAS THE
NUMBERS THAT YOU IDENTIFY WITH
SIXTEEN HUNDRED BEING THE HIGH
TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS BEING THE
LOW IS THAT TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
THAT SCALE DOWN ON IT BUT NOW
THAT YOU ARE PRESENTING OF TO
THIS COMMITTEE. SO JUST TO
CLARIFY ASSEMBLY MEMBER I
APPRECIATE THE QUESTION- THE
SIXTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS WAS NOT
MY FIGURE THAT CAME FROM
INDUSTRY HI THERE THAT'S THAT'S
THE NUMBER. YOU'RE FIGURE WAS
FIFTY DOLLARS NO I ALSO I WENT
RIGHT JUST TO CLARIFY AND CLEAR
IF I GET RESPONSE- THE INDUSTRY
HAS SAID THAT THESE ARE WHOLE
HOME ENERGY AUDITS THE SOUP TO
NUTS EXAMINING EVERYTHING YOUR
HOME FOR ENERGY EFFICIENCIES
ARE SIXTEEN HUNDRED I WOULD I
WAS CLARIFYING WAS THAT WE
BELIEVE THAT NUMBER IS GROSSLY
INFLATED THAT ACCORDING TO
CONSUMER WEBSITES. IT THESE
AUDITS COST BETWEEN TWO HUNDRED
AND SEVEN HUNDRED DOLLARS AGAIN
THAT'S THE WHOLE HOME ENERGY
AUDIT THE SOUP TO NUTS LOOKING
EVERYTHING IN YOUR HOME WITH
THE AVERAGE BEING ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED DOLLARS MMM RIGHT NOW
THAT'S AGAIN A WHOLE HOME
ENERGY AUDIT LOOKING AT
EVERYTHING IN YOUR HOME. WHAT
WE ARE TALKING LIKE THERE'S. A
PROJECT SPECIFIC ENERGY AUDITS-
IF THE CONTRA COMES IN PROPOSES.
YOU KNOW CHANGING WINDOWS TO
ENTER EFFICIENT WINDOW. ADDING
SHE YOUR PATH IS THE OPPOSITE
WINS FIVE OKAY WHAT WHAT ARE
THE INNER. PUT IN. ASSOCI WITH
THOSE PROPOSED. IMPROVEMENTS
RIGHT AND HOW DO THEY FIT IN
WITH YOUR ENERGY USAGE WITH
YOUR INCOME. AND ALL THAT
PROVIDING YOU WITH A COSTS THAT
YOU SEE THIS THAT'S THAT'S WHAT
THE AUTO. IN OUR CASE WE DO SO
IT'S NOT A WHOLE HOME ON IT.
WILL BE NARROWLY TAILORED TO
THE PERSON SPECIFIC PROJECT-
pI PULL FIFTY THAT'S JUST KIND
OF LIKE. A GUESSTIMATE MY
ASPIRATIONAL GOAL THAT IS NOT A
FIGURE THAT I HAVE ANY DATA
FOR. BUT I THINK IF YOU DO THE
MATH AND YOU SAY OKAY HOME HOME
AUDIT COSTS BETWEEN TWO HUNDRED
AND SEVEN HUNDRED DOLLARS.
THAT'S SOMEONE COMING OUT
SPENDING SEVERAL HOURS IN YOUR
HOME LOOKING AT EVERYTHING OUT
THERE. VERSUS SOMEONE JUST
COMING TO LOOK AT A SPECIFIC
PROJECT- I WOULD IMAGINE THAT
THE JUST GIVEN THE TIME
CONSTRAINTS AND ALL THAT IT
WOULD BE A LOT LESS. AND AGAIN
I WANT TO JUST REPEAT THE POINT
THAT. I HAVE OFFERED TO THE
OTHER SIDE. HAVING SOLAR WHICH
AGAIN IS ONE OF THE BIGGEST
TYPES OF ENERGY IMPROVEMENTS
ASSOCIATE WITH PACE. TO HAVE
THAT BE A PRO FORMA CHECK A BOX
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK YOU NEED
TO HAVE SOMEONE NECESSARILY
COME OUT TO YOUR HOME YOU CAN
KIND OF LOOK AT YOUR LACK OF
BILL. YOU CAN LOOK AT- DTI
ANOTHER. SIX AND JUST GAUGE
LIKE WHAT THEY NEED AS FAR AS
SOLAR AND BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
THAT WITHOUT A ACTUAL
INSPECTION SO. I'VE OFFERED
THAT AS WELL AND WILLING TO
STOKE ENTERTAIN THAT- BUT THE
GOAL HERE IS TO TRY TO MAKE THE
AUDIT NARROWLY TAILORED AND IS
CHEAPEST POSSIBLE BECAUSE WE'RE
NOT TRYING TO MAKE SOMETHING
THAT. FIRST PEOPLE FROM USING
THE PROGRAM. WE'RE TRYING TO
MAKE SOMETHING THAT- PROVIDES
FARMS CONSUMERS WITH NECESSARY
INFORMATION PROVIDED A CHECK
AGAINST THE TYPES OF FRAUD THAT
ARE UNFORTUNATELY FAR TOO
RAMPANT WITH THIS PROGRAM. NOT
INTENTIONAL EFFORT I MEAN TO ME
TO BE ABLE TO PROTECT THE HOME
OWNER RIGHT NOW. JUST LIKE WE
DID WITH THE LEANS OVER PLAYING
ON THEIR HOMES. HOWEVER DO YOU
HAVE DATA THAT SHOWS. THAT
HOMEOWNERS AND WHAT THEY'RE
ACTUALLY ASKING- THROUGH THESE
PASTE GRAMS OR THE MINIMAL TO
WHAT YOU SCALE DOWN TO A WINDOW
OR TO THE WIDER SCALE. RIGHT
OUT OF THE COST IT'S THEIR- IF
YOUR GOAL IS A- TO FOR. DOLLAR
THAT YOU. AGREED IT'S ONLY A
MINIMAL COMPONENT THAT AVERAGE
USERS ARE GETTING. YEAH WITHIN
THIS PROJECT THAT WILL BRING UP
TO FIFTY DOLLARS DO YOU KNOW.
WHAT THAT. THAT AVERAGE- ASK
IS. OF THE HOMEOWNER FROM THE
PROVIDER- I DON'T THINK WE HAVE
THE DATA AND THAT IS NOT AGAIN
AS I SAID. PUBLICLY AVAILABLE
DATA ON AROUND THE PACE
PROGRAMS NOT BEAR. ONE OF
THINGS WE'RE HOPING IS THAT THE
FBI WILL COME UP WITH THAT DATA
AND I THINK THEY'RE IN THE
PROCESS. POST CODE OF
DEVELOPING PLANS TO DO THAT-
WE'VE HEARD INSTANCES WHERE
HOMEOWNERS GET. AND IT'S PART
OF THE SOMETIMES YOU HAVE THE
CASE THE HOMEOWNER REQUESTING
REPAIR. OTHER TIMES ITS
CONTRACTORS. KIND OF DUPING
HOMEOWNERS AND PROJECTS SO.
WE'VE HEARD REPORTS OF HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS OF HOME
IMPROVEMENT. WE'VE HEARD
REPORTS OF YOU KNOW LIKE. YOU
KNOW FIVE HUNDRED BUCKS A
THOUSAND BUCKS RIGHT SO.
OBVIOUSLY THE SCOPE OF. THE
PARTICULARIZED AUDIT UNDER OUR
BILL. WOULD DEPEND ON THE SCOPE
OF WHAT YOU'RE PROPOSING. BUT I
GUESS I'D SAY YOU KNOW IF IT
SAVES FOUR HUNDRED DOLLARS
RIGHT. WHICH IS THE AVERAGE
COST OF A HOME ENERGY AUDIT.
BUT IT'S FOUR HUNDRED DOLLARS
FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN IMPROVEMENTS I WOULD
STILL ARGUE THAT THAT. IS AN
APPROPRIATE UPFRONT INVESTMENT
PARTICULARLY GIVEN THAT WHEN
YOU ADVERTISE THAT INTO THE
PACE FINANCING STRUCTURE. IT'S
GONNA BE A SMALL SMALL FRACTION
OF THAT RIGHT. FOUR HUNDRED
DOLLARS AS A MEANING FULL CHECK
AGAINST FRAUD AND A HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLAR HUNDRED
THOUSAND OR WHATEVER. ALL HOME
IMPROVEMENT. I THINK IS A
WORTHWHILE INVESTMENT. GIVEN
THE SCALE OF FRAUD WE'VE SEEN
WITH THIS PARTICULAR PROGRAM.
PROVIDE YOU HAVE FOUR HUNDRED
DOLLARS TO BE ABLE TO MOVE
FARTHER WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
AREAS IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
DISADVANTAGE OF PEOPLE OF COLOR
SO. IT DOESN'T AND OF MY
QUESTION THANK YOU FOR A VERY
SHORT I THINK IT'S A NOBLE.
AREA BUT I THINK THERE'S A LOT
OF QUESTIONS STILL AS FAR AS
THAT AND HOW IT'S GONNA
ACTUALLY BURDEN. ALONE ARE
MOVING FORWARD. THANK YOU. FOR
THAT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER VOEPEL.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. MISTER
SAID I'M IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL AND LET ME TELL YOU WHY. I
WAS MAYOR OF MY CITY. AND-
ABOUT TWELVE YEARS AGO ACTUALLY
MAYBE A LITTLE BIT MORE NAP.
THE PACE PROGRAM MADE A PITCH
TO THE CITY TO- DO PAYS. AND
THEY MADE ALL SORTS OF PROMISES
WHICH WERE NOT TRUE IT TO
SHORTEN THIS IT BECAME THE WILD
WEST SO LOOKING AT CURRENT LAW
THAT HAS BEEN PASSED- IT'S
CLEANED UP A LOT OF THE WILD
WEST I BELIEVE YOUR BILL IS THE
LAST PIECE OF THE PUZZLE. TO
MAKE THIS EQUITABLE- WHAT I
FIND CURIOUS AND ODD IT MAY BE
A BILL FOR ANY OF US TO SUPPORT
THE FUTURE. IS WHY DOES THE-
ASSESSMENT THE AUDIT HAVE TO BE
PAID CASH UP FRONT WHY NOT
AMORTIZE IT WITH THE PACE
PROGRAM FINANCING. THAT WILL
BASICALLY TAKE MOST OF THIS
ISSUE ALTHOUGH THE COURT- YEAH
IT'S SO. THE OTHER THING. IS TO
THIS DAY THROUGH MY
NEIGHBORHOOD THE PACE PEOPLE
STILL COME THROUGH DORMITORY
FOR THREE WEEKS I DON'T KNOW IF
I'M UNDER LIST OR WHAT BUT I
DID MY OWN ASSESSMENT I MADE
SEVENTY. SO MOST OF THE PACE
PROGRAM FINANCING IS TWENTY
FIVE TO THIRTY YEARS MY
LIFESPAN EXPECTANCY IN GOOD
HEALTH IS TO AGE. EIGHTY SEVEN-
I'M A LITTLE SHORT THERE. BUT
THEY'RE STILL PETTINESS SO I
BELIEVE THAT THIS ASSESSMENT
THIS AUDIT WOULD BE GREAT
ESPECIALLY FOR SENIOR CITIZENS
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
QUESTIONS FOR YOU SENATOR MAN-
BEFORE I MOVE ON AND WANT TO
KNOW IF ANY OF THE OPPOSITION
WANTS TO REPLY TO. THAT I THINK
WE HAVE A COUPLE PEOPLE ON
THERE BEFORE THE SAID TO STAY
ON THE LINE. REGISTER OKAY-
THIS IS THE OTHER QUESTIONS. SO
I HAVE PO GOING I'M SORRY
SOMEONE MORE THAT MAKE YOUR
COMMENTS- IF THAT'S ACCEPTABLE
THEN. FOR ME I HAVE COMMENTS
ONE ONE QUESTIONS- I THINK-
THAT MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE
SEVENTY FIRST- MAKES A GOOD
POINT ABOUT- HOW THE- AUDIT
WILL GET PAID I THINK THE FACT
OF THE MATTER IS- THAT ISSUE IS
NOT GOING TO BE RESOLVED. UNTIL
AN AUDIT IS REQUIRED ONCE THE
AUDIT IS REQUIRED THEN PEOPLE
ARE GONNA START TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN SO THE
REAL QUESTION HERE IS- IS THIS
MEANINGFUL ENOUGH IS THIS
IMPORTANT ENOUGH. FOR US TO
REQUIRE AN AUDIT AND I WOULD
ENCOURAGE THE AUTHOR TO
CONTINUE TO TALK TO OPPOSITION
ABOUT OTHER OPTIONS THAT- THAT
MIGHT BE OUT THERE- OTHER MAY
IN FACT BE. SOMETHING A LITTLE
LESS SEVERE THAN THE AUDIT
THAT- IS ENVISIONED IT AT AT
THIS POINT. I'M I THINK IT'S
LOOKED VERY VERY LEGITIMATE TO-
BE CONCERNED ABOUT THE IMPACT
OF THE COST OF THE AUDIT ON OUR
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES THE
QUESTION FOR ME IS THAT
OUTWEIGHED BY THE FRAUD THAT IS
BEING VISITED UPON OUR LOW
INCOME OR VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES BECAUSE TO THE
EXTENT THIS CALL CONSUMER FRAUD
IS HAPPENING IT IS TYPICALLY
GOING TO BE- VISITED UPON THOSE
WHO ARE- UNAWARE WHO HAVE
DIFFICULTY UNDERSTANDING WHAT'S
BEING PATCHED- AND- YOU KNOW
FOR ME IT'S CLEAR OF CRITICAL
IMPORTANCE AND SO THE DECIDING
FACTOR TO ME ON THIS- BILL WAS
LISTENING TO THE ATTORNEYS FROM
THAT STATIC. AND FROM IRVINE I
FORGET THE NAME OF THE- OF THE
ORGANIZATION AND THE
TESTIMONIALS THAT THEY PRESENT-
WHICH ARE OUTRAGEOUS I MEAN
TRULY OUTRAGEOUS EXAMPLES OF
CONSUMER FRAUD- SO I THINK THIS
IS- A PROPOSAL IN THE IN THE
BILL IS IMPORTANT AND. TO I
THINK WE OUGHT TO BE MOVING
FORWARD. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ANYONE ELSE FOR
QUESTIONS. SO I HAVE A FEW
QUESTIONS. SO I WAS THINKING
SENATOR SO WHAT HAPPENS IF THE
HOMEOWNER PAYS FOR THE AUDIT
INTERVIEW AUDIT AND THEY DECIDE
NOT TO PROCEED WITH THE PROJECT-
IF THE HOME OUR WORK WILL HELP
IF THE HOMEOWNER WOULD PAY FOR
THE AUDIT. WHICH IS AN F.
BECAUSE WE I WANT TO CLARIFY
AGAIN WE LEAVE THIS OPEN AND WE
BELIEVE IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BLOOM SAID THAT THERE ARE OTHER
THINGS WILL RISE BUT WE ALSO
THINK IT WOULD MAKE FINANCIAL
SENSE FOR CONTRACTORS TO BEAR
THE UPFRONT COSTS AGAIN IF IT'S
A LOW ENOUGH. THRESHOLD AND IT
YOU KNOW THERE TO SAY IT'S
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OR
THOUSANDS OR TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS AND IMPROVEMENTS IF
IT'S A WORTHWHILE PERCENT OF
PROJECTS. I THINK AN HONEST
CONTRACTOR TO I'LL PITCH YOU
THE HUNDRED BUCKS OR WHATEVER
IT IS FIFTY BUCKS WHATEVER THE
COST IS UP FRONT KNOWING THAT
IT CAN ROLL GET ROLLED UP AND I
JUST WANNA CLARIFY I HAVE BEEN
TOLD BY LET'S COUNCIL. THAT
THIS THAT THE UP AUDIT CAN BE
ROLLED IN THE PACE MANSINGH IS
NOT AUTOMATICALLY DONE BECAUSE
THERE IS THE BINARY DECISION
YES NO IF THE HOMEOWNER
ACTUALLY ONCE YOU SPACE. IF THE
HOMEOWNER DECIDES NOT TO SPACE
THEN THE COST OF THAT AUDIT
WHOEVER BEARS IT IS EATEN BY
THE WHOEVER PAID FOR WHETHER
THAT'S A CONTRACTOR THE
HOMEOWNER. OBVIOUSLY YOU CAN'T
GET RULED IN THE CASE. OKAY SO
I'M- SO THERE ANYTHING THE BILL
WHICH FOR PRETTY. THE HOMEOWNER
FOR- IN THE INSTANCE FOR AN
ENERGY AUDIT POINTS OUT
INEFFICIENCIES. IN THEIR HOMES
HAVING NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
REASON THEY'RE INVESTIGATING
THE PROGRAM. I'M SORRY I DIDN'T
HEAR THE QUESTION FULLY IS
THERE ANYTHING IN YOUR BILL
THE- WHICH WOULD PROTECT A
HOMEOWNER IN THE INSTANCE WHERE
AN ENERGY AUDIT POINTS OUT IN A
FINISH INEFFICIENCIES IN THEIR
HOME. HAVING NOTHING TO DO WITH
THE REASON THEY'RE
INVESTIGATING THE PROGRAM SO IF
IT I GUESS THE QUESTION IS IF
AN ENERGY AUDITOR WOULD TO
FRAUDULENTLY POINT OUT. THINGS
THAT WERE. NOT THERE LIKELY
THEY WERE TO SAY YOU HAVE LIKE
A GAS LEAK OR IN ENERGY
EFFICIENT WINDOWS- OFFERED TO
MAYBE- STACY TALK HERE BUT I
WAS IN THAT BE FRAUD- AND
PROTECTED BY. EXISTING
CONTRACTUAL CRIMINAL FRAUD LOSS
BUT- MISS CUT FROM YOU SEE I
CONSUMER LAW CLINIC MIGHT BE IN
A BETTER POSITION TO ANSWER
THAT QUESTION. YES AND YOU KNOW
IT. MY UNDERSTANDING IS THE
SAME AS SENATOR MAN THAT WOULD
BE MY RESPONSE IT IS THAT YOU
KNOW IF THERE IS FRAUD THAT'S
COMMITTED UNDER THE ENERGY
AUDIT WORK FRAUDULENTLY
RECOMMENDED AND I BELIEVE THAT
THERE WOULD BE RECOURSE FOR THE
HOMEOWNER IN THOSE.
CIRCUMSTANCES THOUGH I HAVE TO
BUT I CAN SOMEONE INTERPRET
YOUR QUESTION A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENTLY WHICH IS S. B. AT
ENERGY AUDIT- LOCATED AB OTHER
IMPROVEMENTS THAT COULD BE MADE
OR MORE COST EFFECTIVELY MADE-
WHETHER OR NOT DEAD THAT THE
HOMEOWNER WOULD BE ABLE TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH THOSE. OR MOVE
FORWARD WITH THE CASE FINANCING
AND M. AND IT WOULD BE MY
UNDERSTANDING ON THE WAY THAT
THE BILL AS CURRENTLY WRITTEN.
THE ENERGY AUDIT AND COVERS
OTHER IMPROVEMENTS THAT CAN BE
DONE AS LONG AS THEY ALIGNED
WITH THE GOALS OF THE PEACE-
PROGRAM AND THE APPROVED. ANY
IMPROVEMENTS THAT ARE ALLOWED
WITHIN THAT WHICH I WOULD
IMAGINE THEY ALL WOULD UNDER
THAT SCENARIO. THEN THE
FINANCING COULD BE USED FOR
OTHER IDENTIFIED PROJECTS WITH
IN- THAT AUDIT- AND TO ALLOW
THE HOMEOWNER THAN TO PICK AND
CHOOSE WHAT IS MOST IMPORTANT
AND MOST COST EFFECTIVE. FOR
THEM TO GET FINANCING FOR
ENERGY EFFICIENT IMPROVEMENTS
AND THAT'S REALLY THE WHOLE
GOAL OF THESE ENERGY AUDITS IS
TO GIVE HOME OWNERS A LIST OF
IMPROVEMENTS. AND AN
UNDERSTANDING OF THEIR COSTS.
IN ORDER TO DETERMINE WHETHER
OR NOT THE COFFEE BEANS FROM
THE ENERGY EFFICIENT PROGRAMS
WILL BE ASKED PROMISED- AND
WILL ALLOW IT TO BE AFFORDABLE
THEN FOR THE HOMEOWNERS AND
AGAIN THESE ENERGY AUDIT
PROGRAMS AND THE
RECOMMENDATIONS WITHIN THE BILL
OF THE SPECIFIC ENERGY OUT OF
PROGRAMS THAT ARE NEEDED. DO
YOU HAVE REGULATIONS GOVERNING
THE WAY IN WHICH ARTISTS NEED
TO BE DONE AND ENSURING THAT
THEY ARE DONE IN A
PROFESSIONAL. MANNER AND
CONSISTENT WITH THAT THE
REGULATIONS. AND TRAINING
MANUALS THAT ARE PROVIDED. OKAY
CENTER BUT THAT'S NOT YOUR BILL
SAYS I'M SORRY THANK NOT WHAT
YOUR BILL SAYS WELL I'M SO WHAT
WHAT PART OF THE WHAT IS THIS
MY BILL NOT SATISFY I JUST SAID
THAT'S HOW IT'S GOING TO BE
HANDLED ON- THE OFFICIALS IN
THE HOME HAVING THAT IS THE
REASON FOR MESSI THE PROGRAM SO
THAT'S NOT EXACTLY YOUR DANCE
WASN'T REALLY WITH AND WHAT ARE
YOU REFERRING TO HER TESTIMONY-
BOTH OKAY SO AS FAR AS WHAT I
SAID IF I MIGHT HAVE PERMISSION
YEAH- I SAID I DON'T KNOW I
WOULD ASSUME THAT FRAUD ON THE
MARKET- CLASSIC CONTRACTS
PRODUCT EERIE. AND OTHER
GENERAL LOTS OF APPLICABILITY
WOULD APPLY TO ANY MISTAKE A
MATERIAL MISSTATEMENT IN AN
ENERGY AUDIT I ASSUME WOULD BE
COVERED BY COMMON LAW CONTRACT
FRAUD PRINCIPLES IT DOESN'T SAY
THAT THE BILL BUTTHAT OF
COURSE WOULD BE MY
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW OUR BILL
WOULD INTERACT WITH EXISTING
LAW AS FAR AS MISS PUTS THIS
MONEY I BELIEVE THAT YOU KNOW
IF AN ENERGY AUDIT SHOWS
ADDITIONAL PROJECTS IN THE
HOMEOWNER DECIDES TO WANT TO
TAKE THEM UP I BELIEVE THE BILL
WOULD GIVE LICENSE TO DO
ANYTHING APPROPRIATE RIGHT-
OPPOSITE THE AUDIT ITSELF WOULD
COVER THE PROPOSED
IMPROVEMENTS. SO IF FOR EXAMPLE
UNDER HER SCENARIO AND ENERGY
AUDITOR CAME IN AND IN DECIDED
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO LOOK AT THE
WINDOWS BUT THEY ALSO LOOK AT
YOU KNOW MAYBE THE DOORS AND
THE DRAFTY DOORS- AND INCLUDE
AN ENERGY AUDIT WELL THAT NOW
IS COVERED AS PART OF THE AUDIT
WHETHER OR NOT WAS PAID FOR UP
FRONT TO BE PAID FOR SO IF THE
HOMEOWNER AND CONTRACTOR
DECIDED P. PROCEED WITH PACE- I
WOULD ASSUME THAT OULD WORK-
IT DOESN'T SAY THAT IN THE BILL
BUT I SEEM JUST THE WAY THE
BILL WORKS. WITH EXISTING LAW
THAT WOULD BE COVERED. REMINDS
IS GIVEN OPPORTUNITY FOR UPS.
I'M SORRY WHAT AND- JUDY FOR UP
SELLING SO. THAT'S REFERENCE.
IS RIGHT NOW IS BECAUSE A LOT
OF. YOU HAVE SOME. AND I'M A
THERE'S A LOT HERE THAT NEEDS
TO BE TAKEN CARE OF I MEAN WE
CAN'T ASSUME WHEN WE'RE MAKING
THE BILL. WE HAVE TO BE PRETTY
CUT AND DRY AS WE DO THESE AND
YES WE CAN DO A FOUNDATION AND
ADD TO IT. SO I'M- NOT
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT PORTION OF
IT- OKAY I THINK THAT'S MY
QUESTION FOR RIGHT NOW YES
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. OF I'D I'D I'D
THINK THERE MAY BE SOME
MISUNDERSTANDING HERE- MY
UNDERSTANDING OF THE AUDITOR'S
RESPONSIBILITY IS THAT IT'S
INDEPENDENT FROM- THOSE WHO
WOULD PERFORM THE WORK. SO
THERE WOULD BE NO MOTIVATION A
MINUTE MAYBE I CAN ASK THIS
QUESTION WOULD THERE BE. ANY
MOTIVATION ON THE PART OF THE
AUDITOR TO DO UP SELLING OF ANY
SORT THE AUDITORS GOING TO GET
PAID WHAT THE AUDITOR IS GOING
TO GET PAID FOR PROVIDING A
REPORT AND THAT'S IT. YEAH THAT
WOULD BE THE WAY THAT THIS BILL
IS WRITTEN IN THE AUDITOR IS
INDEPENDENT AND IF YOU PAY THEM
A HUNDRED DOLLARS TO DO A VERY
LIMITED AUDIT I DON'T THINK
THEY WOULD HAVE AN INCENTIVE TO
DO MORE THAN THE SCOPE OF THAT
AUDIT- SO I DO THINK AND THEN
ON TOP OF THAT ADDRESS YOUR
CONCERNS CHAIR AGUIAR-CURRY. I
DO THINK ALSO JUST HAVING THAT
INFORMATION FROM A THIRD PARTY
AS TO THE APPROPRIATENESS OF
THIS THE COST SAVINGS THE
POTENTIAL COSTS. THAT WILL BE
SOMETHING THAT REGARDLESS OF
YOU KNOW WHETHER THERE'S A IN
ITS SENATE BY ANYONE TO UP SELL
THAT'S INFORMATION YOU'RE
ARMING THE CONSUMER WITH THAT I
THINK WOULD BE HELPFUL IN
DETERRING AND PREVENTING AGAIN
THESE AGREE JUST TYPES OF FRAUD
WE'RE SEEING ACROSS THE COUNTRY
IN THE STATE. THAT ARE
IMPACTING- TO THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLOOMS POINTS OUT
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
COMMUNITIES THAT DON'T SPEAK
ENGLISH VERY WELL IT REALLY IS
TARGETING THE ELDERLY OUR MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES AND- I
YOU KNOW THAT FOR ME THIS IS A
RIGHTEOUS BILL IT'S A BILL THAT
CAN HELP IN A MEANINGFUL WAY
AND- I APPRECIATED SOMEONE
MEMORABLE POST COMMENTS AND I.
DO HOPE YOU MAKE IT ANOTHER
THIRTY YEAR SIR. I IF I. IF I.
JUST I WOULD BE CONCERNED IF
THE CHAIRS- COMMENTS ARE ARE
ARE CORRECT- IF THERE WERE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE AUDITOR TO
SOMEHOW- INFLUENCE. WHAT THE-
OF. THE DEPTH OF. THE PROJECT
IN ANY WAY- I'D BE CONCERNED
ABOUT THAT SO IF THE BILL WERE
TO MOVE FORWARD MAYBE THERE'S A
WAY TO TIGHTEN UP THE LANGUAGE
TO MAKE CERTAIN THAT THAT'S NOT
THE CASE. I APPRECIATE THAT
COMMENT AND I DO WANT TO SAY
THAT IF THIS BILL DOES MOVE
FORWARD AT A COMMITTEE I AM
COMMITTED TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH. ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS HERE
INCLUDING OPPOSITION TO TRY TO
MAKE THIS BILL BETTER- THE
GOALS HERE ARE AGAIN TO CREATE
A MEANINGFUL CHECK ON FRAUD. I
WITH AN INDEPENDENT AUDITOR TO
HAPPY TO MAKE THAT LANGUAGE
CLEAR THAT IT MUST BE
INDEPENDENT- I DO BELIEVE THAT
IS ALREADY IN THE BILL BUT I
WILL TAKE ANOTHER LOOK WILL TRY
TO CLARIFY. AND ALLUSIVE DATE
THAT MORE- TO SOME OF THE OTHER
CONCERNS RAISED AROUND
UPSELLING- WE WILL TRY TO
ADDRESS THOSE- IF THIS BILL
MOVES AT A COMMITTEE BUT BUT WE%
ARE COMMITTED. TO MAKING A GOOD
POLICY BILL HERE. SO IF YOU
WANT. THE H. BACK. AND LOOK AT
THE CONTRACTOR AND THE OTHER
SAYS YOU NEED A NEW ROOF- THE
CONTRACTORS HELP SELL FILLING
UP SELLING YOU ON BOTH RIGHT.
WELL I THINK THE WAY THIS BILL
OPERATES THE AUDIT WOULD BE
HAVE TO COVER THE ROOF FOR THE
CONTRACTOR TO BE ABLE TO DO IT
SO THAT THE CONTRACTOR CAME TO
YOU AND SAID I HAVE AN H. BACK
IMPROVEMENT RIGHT NOW THEY ARE
DOING THAT. WOULD SEND YOU THAT
LIVE NATION I CAN COME IN FOR
YOU AND- BY THE WAY A ROOF CAN
HELP TO AND- IT'S GONNA COST
YOU ANYTHING IS GOVERNMENT
FINANCE AND THEN YOU END UP
WITH FIFTY THOUSAND A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND HOME
IMPROVEMENTS THAT GO TO SUPER
PRIORITY LIEN. I WITH THIS
AUDIT REQUIREMENT DO WOULD SAY
THAT IF THE CONTRACTOR NEEDS TO
GET AN INDEPENDENT AUDIT FOR
ALL THE SCOPE OF PROPOSED
IMPROVEMENTS SO IF THEY DON'T
COVER THE ROOF IF THAT'S NOT
COVERED THE ARE THEY CAN'T DO
IT THEN THEY IF THEY WANTED TO
THE ROOF THEY HAVE TO GO GET
ANOTHER ON IT- IF THAT MAKES
SENSE AND SO I THINK THAT WOULD
PREVENT THE TYPES OF- CERTAINLY
DETERMINE THE TYPES OF UP
SELLING THAT WE'RE SEEING- THAT
RUN RAMPANT. IN THIS INDUSTRY.
OKAY WE HAVE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE. OKAY
SEEING NONE WE HAVE A MOTION
AND I AM GOING TO SAY THOSE
FROM OUR BOERNER HORVATH AND
SECOND BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOW.
WE DO- LIKE TO WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE. I JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK
DR- AND I WANT TO THANK YOU
AGAIN- TRIANGULAR CURRY WANT TO
THANK THE STAFF AGAIN FOR YOUR
HARD WORK AND I WANT TO THANK
YOU ALL- NUMBERS FOR YOUR VERY
THOUGHTFUL QUESTIONS IN THIS
DISCUSSION AND I JUST WANT
ARTICULATED AND THAT I AM
COMMITTED TO MAKING THIS BILL
BETTER SO I TAKE YOUR- DERRIUS
COMMENTS TO HEART AND IF IT
MOVED AS COMMITTEE I WILL WORK
TO ADDRESS THOSE AND I STAFF
WILL REACH OUT TO. EACH YEAR
STAFF INDIVIDUALLY TO DO THAT
BUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS. I'M CENTER DRIVE TO
WORKING ON PROTECTING PIT PAYS
FOR CONSUMERS FOR MORE THAN
FOUR YEARS I UNDERSTAND ALL THE
WORK THAT'S BEEN PUT INTO. RAIN
THESE UNSCRUPULOUS ACTORS THAT
ARE PLAYING THE PROGRAM. WELL
PACE IT CERTAINLY NEEDS FURTHER
IMPROVEMENTS IN CONSUMER
PROTECTION FOR THOSE WANTING TO
MAKE THEIR HOMES GREENER AND
MORE EFFICIENT. I TOLD YOU I'M
CONCERNED BY ONE ASPECT OF YOUR
PROPOSAL. AN ENERGY AUDIT HAS
THE POTENTIAL TO BE A USEFUL TO
TOOL AND INSURING THE PROPERTY
OWNERS ARE AWARE OF ANY
INEFFICIENCY IN THEIR HOME. BUT
I DO NOT BELIEVE THE PROVISION
IN YOUR BILL IS THE ANSWER. THE
REQUIREMENT THAT EVERY
APPLICANT TO THE PROGRAM PAY
FOR IT BUT IT IS AN AND
UNNECESSARY MANDATE. ESPECIALLY
IF A PROJECT NEVER MOVES
FORWARD. FURTHER BY RAISING
ISSUES OUTSIDE OF OUR HOME
WALKING OWNER MAY BE
INVESTIGATING THE PROGRAM IN
THE FIRST PLACE. AND A LOT OF
MAY MAY EXACT ACTUALLY INVITE
FURTHER PRESSURE. TO INCREASE
THE SCOPE AND COST OF THE
PROJECT IDENTIFYING ISSUES THE
HOMEOWNER NEVER INTENDED TO
ADDRESS. THIS COULD NOT ONLY
STIFLE THE PROGRAM FOR
HOMEOWNERS FOR WHOM IT MIGHT
HAVE MERIT BUT LYNN THE
CREDIBILITY. TO UNSCRUPULOUS
CONTRACTOR TRYING TO PRESS A
HOMEOWNER TO SPEND MORE. IT IS
A REGRETTABLE THAT YOU CANNOT
AGREE TO WORK TO FIND A MORE
REASONABLE SOLUTION IN THE
AUDIT ISSUE BUT WITHOUT THE
AMENDMENT EVEN THEM THE EVEN
WITH MORE OF WITH IMPORTANT
PROTECTION LIKE REQUIRING. IT
BACK IT LOOKS BUT XIN. I WILL
NOT SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY.
YOU KNOW I OFFERED YOU A
AMENDMENT AND I WISH SHE WOULD
HAVE COUNTED OFFERED AND THAT
WOULD HAVE BEEN A LOT EASIER
FOR ME AND- MANY. OF THEM ARE
NOT TO SPEAK FOR OTHERS BUT IT
WOULD BE A LOT EASIER TODAY AND
I WISH YOU WOULD TAKE IN THE
AMENDMENT. QUESTION IS DO
PASSED TO THE BANKING. AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AGUIAR-CURRY NO. AGUIAR-CURRY
NO LACKEY. LACKEY NO BLOOM.
WILL ARRIVE BOERNER HORVATH.
ABOUT FIVE ALMOST. THIS RIVER
STOPPED LOADING ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS NOT VOTING VOEPEL
I FELT HI YOU HAVE THREE TO.
THANK YOU THANK YOU CHAIRED BY
THE NUMBERS. OKAY. HUNDREDS THE
BILL. OKAY LET'S SEE HERE
REGARDLESS OF THE. LET'S SEE
WERE RESERVED OF THEIR DEATH
PAUL SP SKEWS ME ITEM NUMBER
SIX S. B. TWELVE. WELCOME
SENATOR MCGUIRE. SIX WHAT
HAPPENED. THANK YOU. TWO
HUNDRED OKAY. SENATOR WOULD YOU
LIKE TO BEGIN I APOLOGIZE
THAT'S FINE THANK YOU I WAS
SHOWING OFF A BABY PICTURE YEAH
YOU HAVE EVERY RIGHT TO THAT'S
A BEAUTIFUL BABY THANK YOU SO
MUCH. FIRST AND FOREMOST AT
MADAM CHAIR I JUST WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR IS SINCERE
ENGAGEMENT- INTO YOUR AMAZING
STAFF TEAM AT ANGELA'S BEEN
INCREDIBLE TO WORK WITH AND
JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I AND I WANNA SAY THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS CRITICAL
ISSUE- YOU HAVE BEEN THROUGH SO
MUCH WITH WILDLAND FIRES IN
YOUR DISTRICT THAT WE SHARE
YEAH AND GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
TENACITY ON BEHALF OF THE
RESIDENTS. AND I WANT TO THANK
TO LISTEN. ROB RIVAS CO AUTHOR.
OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER SNOWMAN. I DON'T THINK
WE HAVE ANY ARGUMENT THAT WERE
LIVING IN A PRESS CITY TIMES
WITH WILDFIRES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. THE SIZE AND SCOPE
OF WILDFIRES IN THE STATE OF
CHANGED. FOR LARGER AND MORE
DESTRUCTIVE. RIGHT NOW THAN ANY
OTHER TIME IN MODERN HISTORY.
THAT NEW NORMAL THIS YEAR AND
THAT'S WHY WE BELIEVE THAT WE
NEED SENATE BILL TWELVE. WE
KNOW THE TRADITIONAL
DEVELOPMENT PRACTICES IN HIGH
FIRE RISK AREAS MUST CHANGE.
WHAT IS ALWAYS WORK LIKE SIMPLY
RELYING ON BUILDING MATERIALS
TO WITHSTAND FIRE. NO LONGER
WORKS IN THIS ERA MAKE IT
FIRES. IN HERE'S WHAT OUR NEW
NORMAL LOOKS LIKE. TWENTY SIX
BILLION DOLLARS IN HOMEOWNER
PAYOUTS FROM THE INSURANCE
INDUSTRY AFTER THE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN. EIGHTEEN WILDFIRES
DESTROYED THOUSANDS OF HOMES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. THE NEW
NORMAL MEANS IN THE LAST SIXTY
YEARS. CALIFORNIA WAS BURNING
ON AVERAGE SIXTY YEARS AGO.
UNDER A HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES
ANNUALLY. NOW IT'S NEARLY TWO
MILLION ACRES EVERY YEAR AND
THAT NUMBER WILL INCREASE WHEN
WE TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THE RECORD
FOR A MILLION ACRES FROM LAST
YEAR. THE NEW NORMAL MEANS THAT
ALMOST ALL THE LAND BURNING
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN- NOW
IN HIGH FIRE HAZARD ZONES. FOR
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS LIVE.
THE NEW NORMAL MEANS OF THE
CREEK CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY
GENERAL OFFICE IS NOW
INTERVENING WITH LAWSUITS ON
TWO MASSIVE DEVELOPMENT
PROJECTS IN THE WILD AND URBAN
INTERFACE. BECAUSE OF THE
INADEQUACY OF FIRE SAFETY
REVIEW IN THEIR SEQUEL REVIEW.
IN THE THIRD SEPARATE LAWSUIT
FOUND A MASSIVE DEVELOPMENT IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA HAD AN
INADEQUATE WILDFIRE SAFETY
ASSESSMENT. THAT'S WHY WE NEED
SENATE BILL TWELVE. IT SETS A
MINIMUM FLOOR FOR DEVELOPMENTS
IN THE LARGEST FIRE RISK AREAS
A CALIFORNIA. AND AGAIN I JUST
WANNA BE VERY CLEAR IT'S ONLY
IN THE VERY FIVE I AM VERY HIGH
FIRE HAZARD SO. CURRENT STATE
STANDARDS ARE LIMITED TO THE
BUILDING CODE REQUIREMENT FOR
ROADS AND SIGNS IN FUEL BREAKS.
SB SWELL SETS UP A
TRANSFORMATIONAL PROCESS FOR
THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL TO
ESTABLISH BOLD NEW STANDARDS TO
ENSURE THE DEVELOPMENT AS A
WHOLE. ARE DESIGNED TO WITH.
STAND FIRE NOT JUST THE
BUILDINGS WITHIN THOSE
DEVELOPMENTS. A COUPLE OF
EXAMPLES OF WHAT THIS BILL
WOULD DO. NUMBER ONE- WELL THEN
FIRE HAZARD ASSESSMENT IN
MITIGATION PLAN WOULD NEED TO
BE DEVELOPED. AND IT'S ON A
TIERED STRUCTURE THE MORE YOU
BUILD. THE MORE SANDERS WOULD
BE INCLUDED. DEFENSIBLE SPACE
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT OF FUEL
MODIFICATION REQUIREMENTS AND
ENFORCEMENT OF CURRENT PROGRAMS
ESTABLISHED FUNDED AND
IMPLEMENTED. VIA H. AWAY FUNDS
WOULD NEED TO BE ESTABLISHED.
YOU CAN NO LONGER HAVE ONE WAY
IN AND ONE WAY OUT WOULD HAVE
TO HAVE INGRESS AND EGRESS. AND
A DEVELOPMENT LAYOUT THAT
REDUCE WILDFIRE RISK TO THE
GREATEST EXTENT POSSIBLE.
HOWEVER THIS BILL ALSO REQUIRES
A STANDARD TO BE REASONABLE AND
TO BE FEASIBLE AND ACHIEVABLE
FOR THE MAJORITY DEVELOPMENTS.
THIS MEANS DESPITE WHAT SOME
HAVE SAID COMING INTO THIS
COMMITTEE. SB TWELVE. WILL NOT.
SB TWELVE WILL NOT CREATE A
BLANKET BAN ON NEW DEVELOPMENTS.
CRUCIALLY THE STANDARDS ARE
TIERED SET THE STANDARDS CAN
INCREASINGLY STRONGER AS
DEVELOPMENTS GET LARGER IN HIGH
FIRE RISK AREAS AGAIN THIS IS
ALL BUILT OFF OF COMMONSENSE.
IT STRUCTURED THIS WAY BECAUSE
LARGER DEVELOPMENTS PUT MORE
PEOPLE INTO THE WILL BE HAVING
MORE PEOPLE IN THE WILL BE
MEANS THAT THERE IS MORE
DANGER. THIS MEANS THAT THE
REQUIREMENTS ARE STRINGENT BUT
NOT SO COSTLY IS TO TOTALLY
PREVENT DEVELOPMENT YOU'RE
LOOKING FORWARD I'D LIKE TO
TALK ABOUT SOME AMENDMENTS THAT
WE'RE GONNA BE TAKING. NUMBER
ONE WE'RE GONNA BE AND THEN IN
THE BILL BEFORE THE NEXT
COMMITTEE. TO CLARIFY THAT THE
WILDFIRE REDUCTION STANDARDS
ONLY APPLY TO RESIDENTIAL
DEVELOPMENTS. SO WE'LL BE
TAKING THAT IN ASSEMBLY HOUSING
AND I BELIEVE THAT'S ON JULY
TWELFTH DON'T QUOTE ME ON THE
SPECIFIC DATE. BUT WILL BE
TAKING THAT IN ASSEMBLY
HOUSING. ADDITIONALLY WE HAVE
HEARD THAT SECTION SEVENTEEN OF
THE BILL. COULD IMPACT THE
BORDER FORCE USE REGULATORY
AUTHORITY- THAT WAS NOT AT ALL
OUR INTENTION. TO ADDRESS THIS
CONCERN I'LL BE AMENDING THE
BILL TO REMOVE THE LINE QUOTE
FROM THE PERIMETER. AT THIS
WILL SATISFY CONCERNS AND I'M
GRATEFUL TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THREE OF US FOR ADVANCING THESE
CONCERNS AS WELL WE LOOK FOR TO
WORK WITH YOU SOMEONE OVER ON
THIS. THIS IS THE THIRD YEAR OF
THIS BILL IN THE LEGISLATURE.
IN SENATE BILL TWELVE IS THE
ONLY BILL THAT BALANCES THE
NEED FOR NEW HOUSING. EVEN IN
FIRE PRONE AREAS WITH FIRE
SAFETY. NOW THE SENATE RIGHT
HERE. TOO MANY TIMES IN THE
PAST POLITICS HAS GOTTEN IN THE
WAY OF DATA. DATA THE DATA
SHOWS THAT WE NEED TO CHANGE
THE WAY WE BUILD IN THE WAY WE
REBUILD IN CALIFORNIA. AND IF
WE DON'T. CANDIDLY IN THIS IS
WHAT I'VE SEEN SINCE MY TIME IN
THE SENATE. IF WE DON'T MORE
DEATH AND DESTRUCTION IS GOING
TO FOLLOW. SPEAKING SUPPORT
LAUREN DIFFERENCE HERE IS ON
THE LINE TO BE HALF OF AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION. NO
GRATEFUL THAT WE HAVE AND READ
ON THE LINE TO SPEAK ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA FIREFIGHTERS
LOCAL TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY ONE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH- MEDICINE
NUMBER BUT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AND I THOUGHT I'M SORRY TO GO
ON SO LONG. THANK YOU. ROOM
MOTION FROM- BOERNER HORVATH
AND THE SECOND PART. FROM
MEMORY WITH. STOP IT. OKAY-
OPERATOR WE ARE LOOKING FOR
LAUREN THE VINCE VALENCIA AND
KAREN REED. ALL SIGNS ARE OPEN
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AREN'T ABLE I'M HERE
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION PLEASED TO
BE HERE AT OR ABOUT THE TWELFTH
I WHICH WOULD MAKE A NUMBER OF
VERY IMPORTANT CHANGES
REGARDING PLANNING FOR IN
PERMITTING DEVELOPMENT ON THE
VERY HIGH FIRE RISK AREAS- AS
SENATOR MCGUIRE HAS. POINTED
OUT WE ALREADY KNOW THAT
CALIFORNIA WILL UNDOUBTEDLY
FACE ANOTHER VERY CHALLENGING
WILDFIRES AHEAD PARTICULARLY IN
LIGHT OF RECORD DRY CONDITIONS
AND BADLY OVER THE PAST SEVERAL
YEARS NOW CALIFORNIA CONTINUES
TO FACE RECORD BREAKING
DESTRUCTIVE AND DEADLY
WILDFIRES THAT HAVE BECOME THE
STATE'S NEW NORMAL AND SO
ENSURING JURISDICTIONS WILL
NEED TO DO MORE TO BE BETTER
PREPARED. PLANNING FOR CLIMATE
CHANGE RESILIENCY HAS LONG BEEN
ON THE TOP OF THE. LINE FOR THE
PLANNING PROFESSION. OVER THE
LAST YEARS IT'S BECOME CLEAR.
THAT BOTH THE STEPS WILL NEEDS
TO BE TAKEN DOWN TO BETTER
PREPARE OUR COMMUNITIES ARE
MORE RESILIENT WAYS. THIS MEANS
THREE CAPTAIN HOW LAND USE
PLANNING AND DONE ANY HIGH FIRE
RISK AREAS IDENTIFYING AND
MITIGATING NOT RANKED STRONGER
BUILDING STANDARDS COORDINATING
WITH STATE AGENCIES. AND
ENSURING THAT LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ARE SUPPORTED
WITH GUIDANCE AND FUNDING TO
HELP MAKE THESE CRITICAL
CHANGES AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
THE THOUGHT THAT. A PEACE
ACCORDS THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE WILDFIRE PRODUCTION
STANDARDS UPON YOUR
REQUIREMENTS THE BILL TO ENSURE
THAT EXISTING HOMES THE CARD
NEW DEVELOPMENTS ARE
THOUGHTFULLY CONSIDERED. AND
DEVELOPED IN MCNEESE STANDARDS
THAT ARE REASONABLE AND
FEASIBLE THAT WILL PROTECT NOT.
JUST PROPERTY BUT PEOPLE BY. WE
ALSO BELIEVE THAT SB TWELVE THE
CAL HOW PRAYER BY ENCOURAGING
MARKETS. HALLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT PRACTICES.
APPROPRIATELY DESIGNING
COMMUNITIES IN HIGH RISK AREAS
AND WHERE POSSIBLE REASONS-
REDIRECTING DENSITY PALAK
HAZARDOUS AREAS WITH IN A
JURISDICTION. ALL OF THIS WHILE
IMPORTANTLY MAINTAINING THE
STATE'S HOUSING PRODUCTION
TARGETS FOR EACH REGION TO
ENSURE THAT THE NEED TO DEVELOP
DOES NOT KEEP HOUSING FROM
BEING DEVELOPED BUT GIVE ME THE
NEED TO DEVELOP SAFELY DOES NOT
KEEP HOUSING. BEING DEVELOPED
IN COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA WE GREATLY
APPRECIATE CENTER MAGUIRE'S
TIRELESS EFFORTS ON THIS ISSUE.
AND ENCOURAGE AN AYE VOTE THANK
YOU. THANK THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR ERIN READ- KILEY RIVETING
CAL FIVE LOCAL TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY ONE. WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR HIS WORK ON THIS
BILL HIS EXPLANATION WAS VERY
THOROUGH- THIS WOULD ADD A
LITTLE BIT TO IT- THERE'S A
REASON WHY THE CAL FIRE
FIREFIGHTERS- OVERWORKED
ENTERAGAM ONE. BUT ONCE AGAIN
WORKING TWENTY EIGHT DAYS
STRAIGHT WITHOUT A DAY OFF THEY
MIGHT GET ONE DAY OFF. AND THEN
WORK ANOTHER MONTH- THEY'RE
EXHAUSTED- LOCLE PLANNING IS A
MAJOR CAUSE. OF THE PROBLEM-
SENATOR BOB WEIR HAS BEEN
DEALING WITH THIS ISSUE WITH S.
B. TWELVE AND IN OTHER
IMPORTANT WAYS AS WELL- HE'S
BEEN A TRUE LEADER IN RESOLVING
LONGSTANDING WILDFIRE ISSUES-
AND WE COMMEND HIM FOR HIS
WORK- THE BILL IS IMPORTANT
PART OF. HIS EFFORTS TO MAKE
OUR STATE SAFER FOR THE PUBLIC
AND FOR THEIR OVERLOOKED
FIREFIGHTERS WERE OUT THERE
EVERY DAY- THEY HAVE BEEN ALL
OVER ONE THOUSAND HOURS. MORE
THIS YEAR THAN THEY WERE THIS
TIME LAST YEAR FOUR THOUSAND
MORE FIRES- TODAY- SO IT'S A
SERIOUS PROBLEM AND AGAIN WE
THANK THE SENATOR FOR HIS.
COMMONSENSE BILL- THAT WILL
HELP US IN IN LARGE WAYS WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT YOU
APPROVE SB TWELVE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE WILL NOW MOVE INTO
OPPOSITION WE HAVE ONE IN
PERSON SILVIO. YOUR FURRY-
CALIFORNIA BUILDERS AND
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION PERCENT
THEN THERE WILL HAVE YELLOW
GARBAGE- FROM THE BOARD THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION REALTORS
WILL BE ON THE PHONE. SO
WELCOME SYLVIA THANK YOU IT'S
GOOD TO BE HERE IN PERSON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS SILVIO FERRARI
MAP THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION- CAN YOU
HEAR ME. OK THANK YOU- HERE IN
OPPOSITION- I'VE SAID THIS IN
PREVIOUS COMMITTEE HEARINGS AS
SAY IT AGAIN WE COMPLETELY
AGREE THAT WILDFIRES ARE
GETTING WORSE WE KNOW THAT
THEY'RE GETTING. MORE FREQUENT
MORE INTENSIVE MORE DESTRUCTIVE
WE SEE IT WE KNOW IT WE'RE ALL
LIVING WITH IT- HOWEVER WE
DON'T BELIEVE THAT THE
SOLUTION- IS TO IMPLEMENT A
FIRE REGIME THAT HAS THE
PRACTICAL IMPACT THE REAL WORLD
IMPACT. OF TAKING HUGE SWATHS
OF LAND OFF THE TABLE FOR
HOUSING THAT ARTIFICIALLY
DRIVES UP THE COST TO HOUSING
IN THE EXISTING AREAS WE
ALREADY HAVE RENTS WE ALREADY
HAVE HOUSING COSTS THAT ARE TOO
HIGH. AND LIMITING THE OPTIONS
FOR THE MAJORITY OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO CAN ACTUALLY
AFFORD TO LIVE IN THESE NEW
MASTER PLANNED COMMUNITIES-
THAT'S NOT WISE WE DON'T
BELIEVE WE SHOULD BE DOING
DOING THAT AT THIS TIME. YOU
KNOW CLEARLY AND I HEARD AUTHOR
LOUD AND CLEAR ABOUT SCIENCE
AND DATA I WOULD SAY WE TO
BELIEVE THAT THE SCIENCE AND
DATA IS ON OUR SIDE WHEN IT
COMES TO MASTER PLANNED
COMMUNITIES WE HAVE. SEEN
MASTER PLANNED COMMUNITY AFTER
MASTER PLANNED COMMUNITY TESTED
WILDFIRE TESTED WITHOUT A
SINGLE STRUCTURE LOSS WITHOUT A
SINGLE LOSS OF LIFE. MOST OF
THE PROJECTS THAT WE KEEP
REFERRING TO AN HEARING ABOUT
ARE NOT NEW MASTER PLANNED
COMMUNITIES- WE BELIEVE WHAT WE
ARE DOING IS WORKING AND MAYBE
WHAT'S REALLY NEEDED IS TO SIT
AROUND A TABLE. NOW WE CAN
ACTUALLY KIND OF ALL LOOK AT
EACH OTHER AND DAM IN
DEMONSTRATING WALK THROUGH AND
TALK ABOUT THIS AND GET IT OUT
ON THE TABLE OUT IN THE OPEN-
YOU KNOW WE HAVE BEEN AROUND
THE TABLE. VIRTUALLY SINCE LATE
JANUARY AND NOW THAT WE'RE IN
THE SECOND HOUSE WE JUST REALLY
FEEL LIKE WE GOT TO PUT THE
PEDAL TO THE METAL. AND LAND
SOME OF THESE OUTSTANDING BIG
TICKET CONCERNS I MEAN FOR OF-
THAT'LL JUST ARTICULATE TO YOU
QUICKLY THE FIRST TWO ARE
REALLY KIND OF VERSION OF THE
SAME THEME. BUT THEY HAVE TO DO
WITH WHAT CAN BE EXPECTED OF
YOU AT THE TIME YOU'RE PULLING
A BUILDING PERMIT. SO YOU ARE
STANDING THERE READY TO
CONSTRUCT A HOME EVERYTHING ON
THE FRONT END HAS BEEN DONE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE'S BEEN DONE THE
DEVELOPMENT IS DESIGNED ROADS
ARE IN SEWARD IT'S AN- YOU'RE
PULLING A PERMIT. WE NEED TO
MAKE ABSOLUTE CERTAIN AT THIS
BILL DOES NOT. REACH TRIGGER A
SECOND BITE OF THE APPLE SEQUEL
WE CANNOT AFFORD THAT IS A
DEATH NAILED TO ANY PROJECT
MOVING FORWARD. ON THE SAME
LINE OF THINKING THIRTY FOR
REQUIREMENTS OF RISK REDUCTION
STANDARDS. NUMEROUS PRODUCTION
STANDARDS ON THE HORIZONTAL
STUFF CANNOT BE RE TRIGGERED
CANNOT BE INCORPORATED. THE
BILL ALSO STATE SPECIFICALLY
THAT STANDARDS REGULATIONS
ADOPTED MUST BE REASONABLE
FEASIBLE ACHIEVABLE FOR THE
MAJORITY OF DEVELOPMENTS THAT
MEANS FORTY NINE PERCENT. OF
THE PROJECTS IN AND IN A REGION
CAN BE ON REASONABLE UNFEASIBLE
UNACHIEVABLE WE NEED TO FIX
THAT. AND LASTLY I'VE HARPED ON
OPR FOR MONTHS. BUT WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT- PR CANNOT TRUMP
THE FIRE EXPERTS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF THEIR ACTIVITY THANK
YOU THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT WE
HAVE ANOTHER ON YELLING PERFECT.
ON THE PHONE PLEASE START THANK
YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
KELLY GOT RECKONED WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS OUR ORGANIZATION
REPRESENTS OVER TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND REAL ESTATE
PROFESSIONALS THAT LIVE IN THE
COMMUNITY THEY REPRESENT
MEANING THAT MANY OF OUR
MEMBERS ALONG WITH THEIR
FRIENDS FAMILY AND NEIGHBORS
HAVE LOST THEIR HOMES DUE TO
RECENT WILDFIRES. IN LIGHT OF
THOSE LOSSES AND IN SUPPORT OF
SPOT TRULY REBUILDING THOSE
COMMUNITIES WE'RE HERE TODAY TO
RESPECTFULLY BE IN OPPOSITION
TO SB TWELVE AND AS IT IS
CURRENTLY RAGING WE ARE NOT IN
OPPOSITION TO FIRE STATE
COMMUNITY WE ARE NOT IN
OPPOSITION TO FIRE MINDED LAND
USE PLANNING AND WE ARE NOT IN
OPPOSITION TO PUBLIC SAFETY WE
DEEPLY UNDERSTAND THE
CHALLENGES AND HAZARDS OF
LIVING IN THE VERY HIGH FIRE
HAZARD SEVERITY ZONES AND WE
RESPECT THE INTENT OF SB
TWELVE. WHAT WE ARE AN OBVIOUS
TO ITS THING SB TWELVE. WITHOUT
ADDRESSING OUR REQUEST FOR THE
REASONABLE MANAGE JUST OUTLINED
BY THE BILL. ON BEHALF OF OUR
COALITION. THE HOUSING CRISIS
CONTINUES TO GROW DRAMATICALLY
EVERY YEAR AND SB TWELVE STAMPS
TO EXACERBATE THIS CRISIS BY
PUTTING SWEEPING NEW
RESTRICTIONS IN OUR
ENVIRONMENT. ON SOME OF THE
ONLY AREAS LEFT IN CALIFORNIA
THAT ARE OPEN TO AFFORDABLY A
COMPANY GROW. SB TWELVE IS A
HOUSING GAME CHANGER THIS BILL
IN FUTURE CALIFORNIA HOMEOWNERS
DESERVE TO HAVE THE CONCERNS OF
THE HOUSING COALITION ADDRESS.
BEFORE THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OPERATOR WE OPEN THE- LINES FOR
BOTH- SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION.
TO S. B. TWELVE. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO S. B. TWELVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE
ABOUT EIGHT LINES INTO YOUR
WILL GO TRYING TO FIFTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON JULIET
MALINOWSKI BOTTLE ON BEHALF OF
THE FIRE DISTRICT ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA AND THE FIRE
CHIEFS OF CALIFORNIA FIRE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. TRYING TO
SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MARTIN RADAKOVICH ON
BEHALF OF THE TREE CARE
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I'M TRYING TO EIGHTY TO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE THIS IS
CHRISTY BY- ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU EIGHTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE NUMBERS
PERSONAL CHAOS ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY EFFECTIVELY HELP AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK YOU
VERY FEW. THANK YOU EIGHTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
CHAIRED MEMBERS COMMITTEE ADAM
RACKLEY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN WILL
DOUBLE OPPOSITION I WANT TO
THANK THE- CONSULTANT AND
AUTHOR FOR THEIR WILLINGNESS TO
WORK WITH THAT AND THE CORD TO
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
KßT WRONG WITH THE LOCAL
REPRESENTS A CALIFORNIA WE DO
NOT HAVE A PROPOSITION ON THE
BILL BUT WOULD LIKE TO THANK
FARM ACQUIRE AND HIS STAFF
LOOKING TO CONTINUE TO ENGAGE
WITH THE WORLD COUNTY BEAUMONT.
AND PORT CALLED THE MATTER WITH
THE COURT AND FURTHER
DISCUSSIONS ON THE IMPACT OF UP
TO TWELVE OF MOBILE GOVERNMENTS
AND SOME. REPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
SURE MEMBERS THEY ALL BROUGHT
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
LAFAYETTE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
TRYING TO EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRED
MEMBER THIS IS CHRIS WILSON
WITH LOS ANGELES COUNTY
BUSINESS FEDERATION WE ARE
OPPOSED TO SB TWELVE COOLEY
BRITAIN THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU OPERATOR ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. YES ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAMOS. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND THANK YOU FOR A-
IN THIS- IMPORTANT- BILL
FORWARD I THINK WE TALK ABOUT
THE FIRES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE KNOW THAT THEIR
TIME EVERY YEAR. BUT WE ALSO.
NOTE THAT FIREFIGHTERS PUT
THEIR LIVES ON THE LINE OUT
THERE DAY AND NIGHT FOR US. SO
WE KNOW THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT PIECE OF LEGISLATION
TO MOVE FORWARD. IN THE
PROTECTION OF PREVENTIVE THIS
UP TO MAKE SURE THAT WHEN-
FIREFIGHTERS ARE CALLED INTO
ACTION THAT THERE'S- DEFENSIBLE
SPACES IN THOSE THINGS THAT ARE
THERE. SO IT'S VERY IMPORTANT-
BUT IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO
BRING THE STAKEHOLDERS WITH THE
QUESTIONS THAT THEY HAVE.
FORWARD TO TRY TO FIND THAT
BALANCE IT'S THERE. THIS BILL-
STARTS TO MOVE FORWARD- IN THAT
IN THAT MANNER- MAKING SURE
THAT OUR FIREFIGHTERS ARE OUT
THERE AND EQUIPPED AND THEY
HAVE THE VOICE IN THE PROCESS
TO MAKE SURE. THAT THERE'S-
ACTION THAT'S DONE PRIOR TO THE
CALLING NINE ONE ONE AND THEY
RESPOND AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL DOES START TO DO SOME OF
THAT PREVENTIVE MISFITS THERE.
HOWEVER THERE IS SOME SERIOUS-
CONCERNS FROM THOSE THAT ARE IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME. AND WE
WOULD LIKE TO CONTINUE TO SEE
THAT DIALOGUE CONTINUE TO MOVE
FORWARD. WE KNOW THAT THIS BILL
IS IMPORTANT BUT WE ALSO WANT
TO MAKE SURE THOSE VOICES ARE
BEING HEARD. AS FAR AS THE
HOUSING AS FAR AS SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN ALLUDED
TO. I JUST WANTED TO GET THAT
COMMITMENT FROM ROM THE CENTER
THAT YOU ARE GOING TO BE
CONTINUING TO MOVE FORWARD IN
THAT. HOW 2% SO NUMBER THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THOSE COMMENTS
AND VERY GRATEFUL- YES 1100%
COMMITTED TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH OPPOSITION I THINK THAT
IS. GOING TO BE ABSOLUTELY
NECESSARY AS WE MOVE FORWARD-
WERE TAKING A MEANS IN THE NEXT
COMMITTEE THAT I DO BELIEVE.
THAT NOT THAT CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION I
DON'T WANT TO. SAY THAT BUT-
THERE ARE AMENDMENTS THAT WE'RE
GONNA BE TAKING IN THE UPCOMING
COMMITTEE THAT WILL ALLEVIATE
CONCERNS- AND WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO WORK. ON ADDITIONAL
AMENDMENTS YOU HAVE MY WORD ON
THAT- ALONG WITH THE CHAIR AND
SOMETHING TO CHEER ALSO.
DISCUSSES WHETHER WE CONTINUE
TO MEET. WITH OPPOSITION AND
WE'VE BEEN DOING THAT THE
ENTIRE TIME AND I WILL CONTINUE
TO THAT NOW. THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH SIR I'M VERY
GRATEFUL. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- I KNOW THAT YOU'VE DONE.
A LOT OF WORK ON THIS BILL AND
I JUST WANNA LET YOU KNOW THAT
I APPRECIATE YOUR ENGAGEMENT
WITH MY OFFICE AROUND- SOME
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD. AND
FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS ISSUE.
THANK YOU IN. GREAT GREAT
AWESOME THE NUMBER AND WE WILL
BE TAKING THE PRIMARY LANGUAGE
OUT- IN THE NEXT COMMITTEE AND
ALONG WITH THIS MEMORY IN VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR ENGAGEMENT
AS ALWAYS MADISON THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND I TOO
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
THE HARD WORK THAT'S GONE INTO
THAT. AND INTO THIS BILL- I
SUPPORTED A STRICTER- A MEASURE
THAT WAS VETOED BY THE
GOVERNOR- SO I GUESS THAT TELLS
YOU A LITTLE BIT ABOUT. OF
WHERE I STAND AND- I THINK
YOU'D BE HARD PRESSED TO FIND
TO- A MORE VOCIFEROUS- ADVOCATE
FOR- BUILDING. MARKET RATE AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA- BUT WE DO HAVE
TO BE. VERY VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT PUBLIC SAFETY AT THE SAME
TIME- WE HAVE- EXPERIENCE TO A
WILDFIRE AFTER WILDFIRE AFTER
WILDFIRE AND SEEN- THE TRAGIC
CONSEQUENCES AND I DO
UNDERSTAND THAT- BETTER
BUILDING STANDARDS- ACHIEVE
BETTER RESULTS WHEN IT COMES TO
PROTECTING AGAINST A FIVE- BUT
IT'S NOT JUST BUILDING
STANDARDS WE HAVE TO BE
CONCERNED ABOUT INGRESS AND
EGRESS AND I KNOW SENATOR-
YOU'VE BEEN TO THE INCIDENT
COMMAND YOU BEEN TAKEN OUT OF
ON TOURS LIKE I HAVE WITH THE
SCENES OF SOME OF THE WORST
FIRES AND- IN CALIFORNIA OVER
THE PAST FEW YEARS YOU'VE SEEN
THE- BURNT OUT CARCASSES OF-
VEHICLES IN. PLACES WHERE
PEOPLE HAVE PERISHED AS A
RESULT OF- THERE BEING A LACK
OF ABILITY TO GET OUT AND HOW
IT WAS DIFFICULT FOR FIRE
SERVICES TO GET IN TO- AND
EMERGENCY SERVICES TO GET IN TO
VERY AS FAR AS- SO THESE ARE
EXTREMELY M. AND- IMPORTANT-
ISSUES. AND AGAIN I THINK THE
BETTER STANDARDS DO OFFER SOME
PROTECTION- AND THEY'RE
CERTAINLY APPROPRIATE FOR- FOR-
REBUILDS AND REMODELS. BUT I
THINK WE NEED TO BE. VERY
CAREFUL ABOUT MAKING BLANKET
STATEMENTS ABOUT JUST YOU KNOW
THAT WE WOULD- LOCATE NEW
DEVELOPMENTS IN HARM'S WAY- AND
I'M VERY VERY CONCERNED THAT WE
NOT HEAD DOWN THAT PATH I DON'T
THINK YOUR BILL IS INTENDING TO
DO THAT- IN ANY WAY SHAPE OR
FORM- AND I THINK THAT- THE
BILL'S A SIGNIFICANT
IMPROVEMENT. OVER WHAT THE LAW
IS TODAY- SO I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL I DO HAVE
FIVE ONE REMAINING ISSUE THAT
WE'VE SPOKEN ABOUT BRIEFLY AND-
THAT IS WHETHER- I THIS BILL-
SPECIFICALLY ADDRESSES ISSUES I
THINK IT'S CLEAR- AND- I'LL ASK
YOU TO CLARIFY AGAIN THAT- OF
THE BILL- DOES NOT. ADDRESS
COMMERCIAL STRUCTURES OTHER
THAN IN A MIXED USE TYPE OF
CONTEXT- BUT- SCHOOLS AND-
UNIVERSITIES FOR EXAMPLE WHICH
IS OF SIGNIFICANT CONCERN AND-
ONE AREA THAT I REPRESENT ARE
NOT COVERED. AND I WILL JUST
SAY FOR THE BENEFIT OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE CASE OF THE ONE
UNIVERSITY THAT I KNOW OF THAT
EXISTS AND- THE- HIGH FIRA
HAZARDS. STONE THAT WOULD BE
PEPPERED NINE- THEY HAVE- IN MY
DISTRICT TO IMPLEMENTED- THE
HIGHEST STANDARDS OF FIRE
PROTECTION AND OF WITHSTOOD
SEVERAL- FIRES THAT HAVE COME
THROUGH THE AREA- BUT THEY'RE
CONCERNED THAT THEY MIGHT HAVE
TO- OF THE SUBJECT TO A
DIFFERENT STANDARD AS A RESULT
OF THE BILL WHAT THEY'RE-
ALREADY DOING AND- YOU'VE
OFFERED TO WORK WITH MY OFFICE
AND MYSELF TO. CLARIFY. AT THAT
ENSURING FOR **** THAT. THROUGH
THE CHAIR. I THANK YOU SO MUCH
FANFARE DOUBT FOR SOME
PHARMACISTS IN THEIR BLOOM IS
BEEN CHAMPION IN THIS
LEGISLATURE AND- FIRE
PREVENTION- IN AS WELL AS
FIREFIGHTERS AT THROUGH HIS
ROLE IN BUDGETS UP AND JUST
WANNA TAKE MOM TAKE KNOWLEDGE
THAT. I BECAUSE NOT ONLY YOU
FOCUS ON HOUSING SIR YOU'RE
ALSO FOCUS ON FIRE PREVENTION
IN THE IMPACT IT IS HAVING A
DISTRICT IS ONE AYE AYE
PUBLICLY SAY THANK YOU ON THAT-
SO WE WILL BE TAKING AMENDMENTS
TO BE ABLE TO CLARIFY IN SENATE
AND ASSEMBLY HOUSING. IT WILL
ONLY BE FOCUSED ON THE ISSUE OF
HOUSING THE CURRENT VERSION OF
THE BILL PRECLUDES COMMERCIAL-
BUT IT WOULD TAKE IN IN THIS
CURRENT VERSION NOW WOULD TAKE
IN- OTHER FORMS OF DEVELOPMENT.
SO WHAT WE'RE GONNA BE DOING IN
SENATE HOUSING IS CLARIFYING.
THAT THIS BILLS ONLY FOCUS ON
HOUSING. NOW THAT WOULD STILL
MEAN STUDENT HOUSING WOULD BE
IN THE BILL AND THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT WOULD LIKE TO BE
A TO GET FURTHER INFORMATION
WITH YOU ON AND WORK WITH YOU.
AS WE MOVE THANK YOU HAVE A
STUDENT HOUSING WAS PROBABLY
NOT SOMETHING YOU'RE THINKING
ABOUT. IT IN THE CONTEXT OF
HOUSING GENERALLY SO I
APPRECIATE THAT NO 100% SIR IN
THE FOUR TO OUR ON GOING
DIALOGUE AND I'M GRATEFUL FOR
THE COMMON QUESTION SIR THANK
YOU. FOR ARE THERE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE-
LET'S SEE DID HAVE A- ON QUITE.
THE MOTION HERE LET'S SEE HERE.
BOERNER HORVATH HUH IN SECOND
BY PHONE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ROBERT RIVAS. DID YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU SO MUCH-
MENTOR TO SORT OF SAY AT NUMBER
ONE ON THE ISSUE OF SYKORA-
THERE ARE TWO CHALLENGES AND
SEEK WHY THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE IS CHALLENGING TO SECRET
DOCUMENTS AND THERE IS A
SEPARATE ISSUE ON A SECRET
DOCUMENT DOWN- IN NORTHERN L.
A. COUNTY SO THE ISSUE SEQUIN
WILDFIRE SAFETY REGARDLESS OF
THIS BILL IS ALREADY HAPPENING
JUST BEING HONEST ABOUT IT. AND
YOU HAVE MY COMMITMENT THAT
WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO WORK
OUT WITH OPPOSITION IN ALL
SIDES IN RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE AND I'M VERY
GRATEFUL TO BE IN FRONT OF YOU
TODAY THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU FOR THE ROBUST DIALOGUE
MEMBERS GREAT THANK YOU SENATOR
AND YOU KNOW GET A BIG LUMP IN
MY THROAT RIGHT NOW BECAUSE I
KNOW. FIRES ARE RIGHT AROUND
THE CORNER IN HERE WE GO AGAIN
AND SO I KNOW THAT YOU'VE
WORKED ON THIS AND YOU CONTINUE
TO WORK ON THIS ISSUE. I'M
FOURTEEN OR MUTUAL CONSISTS
CONSTITUENTS LIVE WITH THE
HEAVY BURDEN OF EXTREME
RECURRING WILDFIRES MEASURED
DEEP COMMITMENT TO PROTECT THEM
EVERYONE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FROM THE DEVASTATION
HARBORING. THESE DISASTERS
BECAUSE- ALSO WE ALSO SHOW THE
GOAL OF. THE NEED TO BUILD
SMARTER FOR THEIR STATES
DESPERATE NEED FOR MORE
HOUSING. FIND THE SPELL OF IS
BEEN VERY DIFFICULT AND THE BIG
TASK AND I APPRECIATE THE TAKE
IN THE SONG. SO AS WE DISCUSSED
I KNOW YOU WILL WORK ON THIS
FOR TWO YEARS TENURE CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS
ON ON REFUND RESULTS CONCERNS
ESPECIALLY THOSE. THAT I'VE
JUST BEEN MADE AWARE OF THIS
WEEK. I APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMITMENT TO KEEP THIS
COMMITTEE INFORMED ON YOUR
PROGRESS. I SUPPORTED SB ONE
EIGHTY TWO LAST YEAR AND I WILL
BE VOTING ON IS B. TWELVE
TODAY. I LOOK FORWARD TO
SUPPORTING HIM EVEN BETTER BILL
ON THE FLOOR. THE GOALS OF
PROVIDING HOUSING AND
INCREASING THE SAFETY. OF OUR
COMMUNITIES MUST BE COORDINATED
SO THAT OUR CITIES AND COUNTIES
CAN PLAN BETTER. THAN CHEAP AND
ACHIEVE SAFE RESULTS. THE
MOTION IS A DO PASSED TO THE
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AGUIAR-CURRY HI AGUIAR-CURRY
HAI LACKEY. LACKEY LOW BLOOM.
HELLO I'VE BOERNER HORVATH.
RIVERBANK HIGH ROBLES. ROBLES I
LOOSELY. THREE OF US I RIVER.
WEBER READ VOEPEL. TELL YOU
HAVE SIX TO BILLS OUT SIX TWO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS.
OKAY THERE SHE WELCOME TO FOR A
COUPLE FRONTIER ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN IS OF THE SENATOR MELINDA
THIS. AND WELCOME IT'S NICE TO
SEE YOU. MOVED ABOUT. HERE WE
GO THE RUSSIAN MARKET- LUCKY IN
THE SECOND BY MR VOEPEL FOR
OKAY EVERYONE WE GO WELL GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE IT IS VERY
NICE TO SEE ALL OF YOU AGAIN- I
AM HERE TO PRESENT SB THREE
NINETEEN- WHICH IS SPONSORED BY
THE DESERT VALLEY BUILDERS
ASSOCIATION. CURRENTLY IS LIES
WRITTEN IN AGENCIES OBLIGATED
TO PROVIDE ANNUAL REPORTS
IDENTIFYING REVENUES COLLECTED
AND EXPENDED AND THE SPECIFIC
USE OF THOSE FUNDS SHOULD THE
AGENCY FAILED TO PROVIDE SUCH
REPORTS FOR AT LEAST THREE
CONSECUTIVE YEARS. THE PUBLIC
OR PRIVATE ENTITY MAY REQUEST
AN AUDIT OF THOSE FUND ACCOUNTS
AT THE AGENCIES EXPENSE
UNFORTUNATELY THE SCOPE OF THE
AUDIT IS NOT DEFINED. AND
INTERPRETATION BY A LOCAL
AGENCY COULD LIMIT THE AUDIT TO
ONE YEAR OR THREE HOWEVER IT'S
UNLIKELY THAT THE SUBJECT
AGENCY HAS FAILED TO COMPLY FOR
FIVE OR MORE YEARS BEFORE A
FORMAL AUDIT OF THESE FUNDS IS
REQUESTED. THIS BILL SIMPLY
SEEKS TO FIX THIS BY REQUIRING
AN ENTITY ON EACH YEAR THE
AGENCY FAILED TO PROVIDE THOSE
REPORTS THIS SIMPLE CHANGE WILL
INCREASE TRANSPARENCY AND
ENSURE THE GENERAL PUBLIC HAS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO REVIEW IN
QUESTION ANY NEW OR ADJUSTED
FEES. THIS MEASURE HAS NO
OPPOSITION ENSURE HAS RECEIVED
NO N VOTES JOINING ME TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS GRETCHEN
GETS HERE IS THE CEO OF THE
DESERT VALLEY BUILDERS
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU MEMBERS
AND I REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU SENATOR- POP WRITER
WE'RE LOOKING FOR GRETCHEN GOOD
TO GET IS. THE DESERT. VALLEY
BUILDERS ASSOCIATION ON THE
PHONE. WIDE OPEN THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND
STAFF AS STATED MY NAME IS
GRETCHEN GOOD TERRACE I AM THE
CEO OF THE DESERT VALLEY
BUILDERS ASSOCIATION THE
SPONSOR OF THIS LEGISLATIVE
BILL- THE DBA PROVIDES
LEGISLATIVE AND GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS ADVOCACY THROUGHOUT
EASTERN RIVERSIDE AND IMPERIAL
COUNTIES WITH NEARLY TWO
HUNDRED MEMBERS REPRESENTING
THE HOMEBUILDING CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRIES ONE OF THOSE AREAS
THAT WE PROVIDE REVIEW IN
SUPPORT ON IS THE FEES THAT ARE
COLLECTED UNDER THE MITIGATION
FEE ACT. THAT'S PRESENTED HERE
THE ACT WAS ORIGINALLY
INSTITUTED TO PROVIDE NECESSARY
INFRASTRUCTURE AND SERVICES FOR
NEW RESIDENTIAL COMMERCIAL AND
INDUSTRIAL CONSTRUCTION BUT
WITH OUT BECOMING A BURDEN TO
EXISTING LEVELS OF SERVICE TO
CURRENT POPULATIONS CURRENTLY
THERE ARE ONLY THREE AREAS
THAT- WE HAVE OPPORTUNITIES IN
WHICH TO REVIEW THOSE FEES
WHETHER THEY BE NEW OR
INCREASED IMPACT FEES ONE IS
DURING THE INITIAL NEXT TO
STUDY FOR SUPPORT OF THAT PEACE
GADGIL THE SECOND IS DURING THE
ADOPTION OF A CAPITAL
IMPROVEMENT PLAN BY THE
GOVERNING AGENCY DURING THEIR
ANNUAL BUDGET OR AT ANY OTHER
TIME THAT THEY WISH TO CONVENE
A CAPITAL IMPROVEMENT PLAN. AND
THE THIRD OPTION IS DURING THE
REVIEW AT THEIR ANNUAL AB
SIXTEEN HUNDRED REPORT PROCESS
WHICH IS GOVERNED UNDER
GOVERNMENT SECTION CODE SIXTY
SIX I WAS- SIX AND SIXTY SIX OH
OH ONE CURRENTLY THE GENERAL
PUBLIC IN BUILDING COMMUNITY
DOES NOT HAVE THE OPTION-
TYPICALLY OF LOOKING AT CAPITAL
IMPROVEMENT PLANS WHICH THEN
MEANS THAT WE ONLY HAVE THE
OPTION OF LOOKING AT ONLINE YOU
WILL I SPACES FOR THE REVIEW OF
THAT REPORTING THAT THE AGENCY
WOULD PROVIDE. UNDER THE
TRANSPARENCY OF THE MITIGATION
FEE ACT CURRENTLY IN THE WORKS
UP IN THE SPONSORS REGION MORE
THAN 20% F THE AGENCIES FAIL
TO REGULARLY FILE THOSE ANNUAL
REPORTS THE REMAINING 80% OF
AGENCIES- TWO THIRDS OF THEM
CONTINUE TO MISS APPROPRIATELY
USE THOSE FUNDS AT CENTER
MELINDA'S JUST STATED SENATE
BILL TWELVE OH TWO WHICH WAS
ADOPTED AND SIGNED BY GOVERNOR
BROWN IN SEPTEMBER. OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN INSTITUTED THE THAT
AGENCY FAILING TO REAP FOR
THREE. YEARS COULD BE SUBJECT
TO AN AUDIT. THIS BILL SENATE
BILL THREE NINETEEN CLARIFIED
THE NUMBER OF YEARS THAT THAT
AUDIT WOULD ENCOMPASS AND WOULD
STATE THAT FOR EACH CONSECUTIVE
YEAR THE AGENCY FAILED TO
PROVIDE THEIR AND REPORT. AS
REQUIRED PURSUANT TO THE
MITIGATION FEE ACT THAT YOUR
WOULD BE AUDITED THEIR BY STAFF
WISHING A CONSECUTIVE PATTERN
OF REPORTING. WE THANK SENATOR
MELINDA FOR INTRODUCING THIS
BILL LEGISLATION AND WE URGE
YOU TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO AN
AYE VOTE OF SUPPORT FOR SB
THREE NINETEEN. THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
DON'T HAVE ANYBODY THAT'S FOR
OPPOSITION- OPERATOR LET'S OPEN
UP THE- PHONE LINES FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION JUST YOUR NAME.
ADDITION AND YOUR ORGANIZATION
PLEASE. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE NINETEEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE
ONE LINE IN CUBA LIGHTENED TWO
EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS MICHAEL DOWNING
HERE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE NINETY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THE
OTHER ON THE LINE. I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE- WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SOME REMEMBER
LUCKY A SECOND BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER VOEPEL. HOW WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR I WANT TO BE RESPECTFUL
OF YOUR TIME CHANGE- IT'S BEEN
A LONG AFTERNOONS I WOULD JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I JUST
WANNA SAY. I LOVE. WITH YOU CAN
HAVE GOOD. GOVERNMENT
TRANSPARENCY IS ONE OF THE TOP
OF THINGS AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE BEING THE BILL FOR
TONIGHT HOW WILL BE. SUPPORTING
YOUR BILL AND THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE LACKEY. LACKEY
AYE BLOOM. AYE BOERNER HORVATH.
RAMOS RAMOS I'D LOSE RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS I
WILL TELL THE TALE I HAVE SIX
ZERO GOOD READ THE BILL THAT WE
WILL CALL THE ROLL OPEN FOR ADD
ONS THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
FOR PRESENTING THE BILL THANK
YOU SO MUCH MEMBERS PRECIADO
YEAH. HI IS THE RELY. CENTER
AND BE DONE GOOD FOOD. THE
SERVER WHITE HOUSE HERE SENATOR
STERN. OFFICE YEAH OKAY THANK
VERY MUCH WE'RE GOING TO GO
AHEAD AND DO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR COULD ENTERTAINMENT
MOTION. OKAY WE HAVE A ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLOOM SECOND VICE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY. THE
SUPPORT WE ARE CURRENTLY HI
AGUIAR-CURRY HI LACKEY LACKEY I
BLOOM. WILL I BERNHARDT. I
PREVENT BOERNER HORVATH HI I
RAMOS FIVE RUBBLE I LOSE RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS I
WILL TELL WITHOUT ARE YOU HAVE
SEVEN ZERO. SIX EIGHT SEVEN
ZERO CORRECT GREAT THANK YOU
VERY. MUCH LET'S MOVE IF YOU
DON'T MIND A DO. OKAY CAN WE
JUST DO REAL QUICK S. THREE
THREE THREE EGGMAN- SHE
ACCEPTED THE AMENDMENT ON THE
BILL. WE NEED A MOTION THE
SECOND ON THE SECOND. YEAH WE
HAVE A MOTION BY ROBERT RIVAS
SECOND BY SOME REMEMBER RAMOS.
AGUIAR-CURRY NINE AGUIAR-CURRY
AYE LACKEY AYE LACKEY AYE BLOOM
BLOOM AYE BOERNER HORVATH
BOERNER HORVATH I'M RAMOS RAMOS
SIGNS RIVAS. ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS I WILL TELL I WILL
TELL HIGH SEVEN ZERO. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SEVEN ZERO
HAVE AN OUT ON LATER. ALL RIGHT.
WE'RE GOING TO ITEM NUMBER TEN
CENTER WHITE HOUSE HE IS SO
NICE TO SEE YOU GOOD EVENING
MADAM CHAIR. FROM WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND MOTION
MILEAGE AND I THINK I'M HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS OKAY WELL
THAT MAKES IT EVEN EASIER. DO
YOU HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. ADRIN RISK AND- NOT
YET ATRION RISK IN EUROPE OKAY
GREAT IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK
PLEASE IN SUPPORT. EIGHT YES
PLEASE. OKAY HI GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS A GREAT RISK AND
YOU'VE HEARD I'M TESTIFYING
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE WHAT IFS
BUT SUNSHINE COALITION AND THAT
THANKS FOR HAVING ME- THE
PRODUCT I REQUIRES LOCAL EVEN
PEOPLE TO PROVIDE THE PUBLIC
WITH THE ENGENDERS BY POSTAL
MAIL A REQUEST OF THE USER
EMAIL REQUIRED THIS BILL I
WOULD AMEND THE ACT TO MAKE
EMAIL NOTIFICATIONS MANDATORY
ON THE REQUEST. FOR AGENCIES
THAT ARE ALREADY ARE. ONLY
CAPABLE OF USING IT AT ALL.
SOME MEMBERS ARE NOT RESPONDING
ASSEMBLY LOCAL BODIES THAT IS A
BODIES NOW COUNTY- EIGHT
INELIGIBLE I DON'T HAVE THERE'S
THE COUNTY ITSELF. THERE'S THAT.
OLD TRUCK POWERED THE PARTY-
EVAN LOW ON. MOBY DON'T THAT'S
NOT AGENDA WILL STOP BY BACK
DOWN FOR A WHILE WE GET A MAJOR
THAT WILL JUST YOU POSTAL MAIL
COULD ALL THE WE ARE TO DO- THE
ONE THAT WE ACQUIRED CALDERON
HERE YOU CAN HELP ANOTHER THE
APARTMENT WAS BUT WE ALL OUT
YOU GET. A PUBLIC AT LEAST
CREEK THAT OUR. SIGNIFICANT I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU'RE GOING TO
GET PROBLEMS FOR MEMBERS AND
PROBABLY. OTHER PEOPLE TO. OUR
THE MAIL BELIEVE. I NAY A JOB
POCKET ONLY NEED TO THAT. OFTEN
DON'T SHOW UP BEFORE MEETING I.
HELLO. ONE IN A WHILE THEY
TENDED- BY MAIL REQUIRED A BIG.
AND MAKE THAT WELL THEM. WHO
OFTEN DON'T GET HOME BECAUSE-
OF. I WE HAVE HOMEWORK NUMBER-
WELL IT HAVE THE THIS CALL
POSTAL BY I OFTEN HAVE. ARE ON
THE WAY BACK THE INTERNET. OUR
I. P. OKAY ANY THIS BILL WOULD
INCREASE PUBLIC AND EATING FIVE
I CALLED THE LOOPHOLE IN
CONFIDENTIAL MALL- THE ONLY IF
I IF YOU YOU THERE ARE YOU THE
AND. LOTUS NOTES TO MAKE BURDEN
PUBLICLY SIGNIFICANT. FOR THESE
WE ARE YOU URGE YOU TO IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL ALL AND
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF THAT
HAPPENED AFTER. ABOUT YEAH
THANK YOU FOR RISK- WE HAVE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES ON SUPPORT
SEEING NONE IN THE GALLERY- I
DON'T SEE. IN OPPOSITION THAT'S
BEEN LISTED- OPERATOR WOULD YOU
OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION NAME. ORGANIZATION
THEM POSITION PLEASE. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION- S. B. TWO SEVEN
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND I DO HAVE TWO
LINES INTO YOUR ONE MOMENTS AT
ALL BY NUMBERS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE JUST ONE
MORE MOMENT HERE. GOING TO
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU HELLO JERRY MEMBER
THIS IS ABRAHAM MENDOZA ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS IN THE
PORT OF THIS MEASURE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE TO
EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS INJURE
ME STRUCTURE WITH THE LEAGUE F
WOMEN VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA
WHERE AND SHOWING SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU
AT THIS TIME ANY QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. HELLO MMHM HELLO.
HI MADAM CHAIR YES THIS IS
PAMELA MILLER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
AGENCY FORMATION COMMISSION
STILL HANGING IN THERE WITH YOU
WE ARE PLEASED THAT THE COURT
SB TWO SEVENTY FOUR GREAT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY SO THEN
THERE'S NO I ACTUALLY HAVE ONE
MORE THANK YOU TO OPT RIGHT
LOOKS LIKE THAT. THANK YOU
LYING TO NINETY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO POSEY LEVIN CHAIR
THIS IS BOB NAY WILL
REPRESENTING THE TRANSPORTATION
CORRIDOR AGENCIES AND WE REALLY
LOVE THIS BILL BUT WOULD LIKE A
CLARIFICATION. THAT EMAIL
REQUESTS REQUESTS ARE EMAILED
MATERIALS AND BE RENEWED
ANNUALLY JUST LIKE REQUEST FOR
MAILED MATERIALS WE DON'T THINK
THE BILL IS CLEAR ON THAT OKAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
ANY OTHER CRAP. IS THERE ANYONE
ELSE ON IN Q. OPERATOR. YOU
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS THANK
YOU OKAY- WE HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE MISTER MICHAELS. WAS
THERE WE HEAR PROPOSITION I
LOVE THE MALL DO IT ALL ONE
TIME EXCELLENT- THE LANGUAGE
WITH MISTER NAYLOR TALKS ABOUT
WAS NEGOTIATING WITH THE
SPECIAL DISTRICTS WE THINK THAT
IT'S CLEAR THE LAST SENTENCE OF
THE BILL SAYS IN ACCORDANCE
WITH THE MAILING REQUIREMENTS.
ESTABLISHED BY TWO PURSUANT TO
THIS SECTION SO AN ABUNDANCE OF
CAUTION BUT THE LEGISLATIVE
RECORD REFLECT THAT THAT WE-
ARE SATISFYING HIS- CONCERNS
AND- WE ASK FOR THE IPHONE OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH IS THE SENSIBLE
TAYLOR BILL TO HELP MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC STAY INVOLVED. WITH
LOCAL GOVERNMENT I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THIS EFFORT THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AGUIAR-CURRY HI AGUIAR-CURRY
I'M LUCKY. THANK YOU I BLOOM.
BLOOM I'VE BOERNER HORVATH HI
BOERNER HORVATH I RAMOS.
PROMOCI THREE OF US. THIS
RIVERSIDE ROBERT RIVAS. HOWEVER
WE DECIDE VOEPEL I WILL TELL
FIVE EIGHT ZERO EIGHT ZERO YOUR
BILLS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY WELCOME- THIS IS A ITEM
NUMBER NINE IS B. FOUR EIGHTY
SENATOR STERN WELCOME. YOU.
THANKS SO MUCH. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS- THINK OF THE
LAST LAST ONE UP HERE OKAY I'LL
TRY TO BE BRIEF- THIS BILL
STEMS FROM SOME REPORTS OF-
VARIOUS MISCONDUCT OCCURRING-
DOWN SOUTH AT A MAJOR- WATER
DISTRICT METROPOLITAN WATER
DISTRICT OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
SEXUAL HARASSMENT OTHER
UNACCEPTABLE AND INAPPROPRIATE
CONDUCT- SINCE SEVERAL
INVESTIGATIONS AND IS CURRENTLY
IN AUDIT UNDERWAY BUT THIS BILL
SORT OF DEALS WITH JUST THE
VERY HIGH LEVEL- MISSION OF THE
ORGANIZATION WHICH IS A-
CREATURE OF A STATE STATUTE AND
SAYS THAT THEY SHOULD ADOPT.
APPROPRIATE MEASURES NOT JUST
ON- PERSONNEL PRACTICES BUT- ON
ON THE SET OF RULES FOR
EMPLOYEE PROTECTIONS ARE AT
THINGS LIKE SEXUAL HARASSMENT-
AND TOWARD CONDUCT- PRETTY
SIMPLE BILL VERY COMPLEX ISSUE-
BUT WE'RE NOT TRYING TO SOLVE
ALL OF IT HERE WE'RE JUST
TRYING TO SAY THEY SHOULD AT
LEAST HAVE SOME OF THE BEST
PRACTICES AND RULES RELATED TO
INAPPROPRIATE CONDUCT BY LAW
pAND NOT LEAVE IT TO THEIR
DISCRETION BECAUSE THAT
DESCRIPTION SEEMS TO HAVE BEEN.
EXERCISED POORLY- AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
NOW MOTION HER POSTAL MEMBER
RIVAS AND AB SECOND BY
BOERNER HORVATH. JOHN RIGHT TO
PROVE LET'S SEE DO YOU HAVE-
YOU KNOW QUESTIONS AUTHORED
WHICH I CLOSE. WE'RE SORRY YOU
KNOW WELL SKEWS ME YOU HAVE A
YOU KNOW SOMEONE WANTS TO SPEAK.
THEY HAVE A WITNESS. YEAH OUR
SHOW TO HIM. YEAH WITH ASKED ME
YEAH I THANK YOU MAY BE ON THE
LINES OKAY ASKED ME IN NINETEEN
OH TWO I CAN ASK HIM TO BE
BRIEF IF YOU CAN. I KNOW YOU
GUYS ARE WRAPPING. STRANAHAN
HELLO. DID YOU HEAR ME OK WE
SURE CAN'T. PLEASE GREAT THANK
YOU CHAIR AT YOUR CURRENT
ARCHER LACKEY MEMBERS ME I'LL
BE EXTREMELY BRIEF BALANCE HERE
TO HAND. OUT THE LOOK LIKE YOU
KNOW IF YOU ALSO DON'T ACTION
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA DROUGHT HE- STRONG
SUPPORT WELL I THINK THE CENTER
FOR BRINGING BILL FOR.
ATTENTION JUST BEGINNING- OF
REFORMS AT THE AGENCY WHICH IS
DEFINED AS YOU'VE PROBABLY SEEN
AN LA TIMES ARTICLE. AND MANY
ARE BAD BEHAVIORS ARE STILL
PROPER CONDUCT BEFORE HAPPENED
VERY- WITH THAT WE BELIEVE
THAT. FORTY IS BUILDING ON WHAT
HE THINKS HE GOT FORTY NINETY
NINE ONE AUTHOR KATIE ABOUT A
PORN AND IT'S JUST BEGINNING.
SO WE RESPECTFULLY. ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS. WHAT FORTY AND
JUST THREE THANK YOU MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU FOR MUCH-
OTHER OTHER SUPPORTERS ARE A OF
THIS BILL. WHEN THE LINE. IF
YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION- SB FOUR EIGHTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME.WE HAVE FOUR IN
Q. WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO NINETY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM
CHAIR SYLVIA BELIEVES SHOT ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SANTA
MONICA AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RYAN TO SEVENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
AND ONE OF THE SHALL BE HAPPY
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU RYAN CHIU
FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD- DURING
MANY MEMBERS MINUS CALL QUERY
WITH THE AMERICAN FEDERATION OF
STATE COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL
EMPLOYEES CALLING IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NO COMMITTEE QUESTIONS WE HAVE
A MOTION AND A SECOND- IF YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOREVER OKAY THANK YOU A
SENATOR FOR OFFERING THIS BILL
ENSURING THE DISTRICT ADDRESSES
INAPPROPRIATE CONDUCT BY BOARD
MEMBERS OFFICERS EMPLOYEES. WE
ALL WANT OUR PLACES ARE TO BE
FREE OF HARASSMENT
DISCRIMINATIONIN THIS BILL
WILL HELP THE HARD WORKING MEN
AND WOMEN OF THE DISTRICT
REATE SUCH A WORK PLACE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AGUIAR-CURRY NIGHT AGUIAR-CURRY
AYE LACKEY AYE LACKEY AYE BLOOM.
WILL AYE BOERNER HORVATH. AFTER
HER DEATH I RAMOS. RAMOS SIDE
THREE OF US HE'S RIVERSIDE
ROBERT RIVAS. ROBERT RIVAS I
WILL TELL. HELLO HI EIGHT ZERO.
FAVOR MORE OF BILLS ON THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR. ALL
RIGHT BEFORE WE NEED TO
ANNOUNCED THE VOTE TALLY IN
RESULT FOR SP FOUR SEVEN SIX BY
SENATOR MAN VOTE WAS THREE TO
MEASURE FAILS SO WANT TO MAKE
THAT CLEAR I'M PROBABLY. AROUND
THE DOOR PRETTY QUICK- SO
MEMBERS WE'VE DISPENSED WITH
THE AGENDA ITEMS FOR THIS
HEARING WILL BELIEVE IN THE
ROLL UP FOR FIVE MINUTES FOR
MEMBERS TO ADD ON. WELL WE HAVE
IT LOOKS LIKE ALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS HERE- WE CAN GO AHEAD
AND DO THAT RIGHT NOW. SB
THIRTEEN DODD THE VOTE IS
CURRENTLY SEVEN ZERO VOEPEL.
JEFF. MADAM CHAIR MAY I ASK FOR
RECONSIDERATION ON S. B. FOUR
SEVENTY SIX. YEAH YES THANK YOU.
OKAY GIVE TRUMP WELL FOR ONE I
THINK THE BOTTOM FOUR SEVEN
FISHER OF FIGURING OUT FROM HIM.
AGUIAR-CURRY. FOUR SEVEN SIX
NINE FOUR FOUR FOUR
RECONSIDERATION YEAH. THAT'S A
GOOD ONE WHY DID WITH LIVE
WHERE I CAME FROM GOING TO
PROVIDE YOU GREAT THE LIST.
HOLD ON JUST. LET'S FOLLOW NINE
FOUR SEVEN SIX LET'S DO THE
REST WILL TRY TO GET THIS KIND
OF PHONE DO YOU WANT TO TALK
TO. HELLO SB THIRTEEN DOG VOTE
IS CURRENTLY THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED. THE VOTE IS
CURRENTLY SEVEN ZERO VOEPEL. HI
VOEPEL HAI THE BILL IS OUT
EIGHT ZERO BILL SB THIRTEEN DOT
ZERO OUT. S. B. THREE THREE
THREE EIGHT THEN THE VOTE IS
THE BOSTON IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROACH THE BOAT IS
CURRENTLY SEVEN ZERO.
THREE OF US THREE OF US I EIGHT
ZERO IS THE VOTE ON THAT SB
THREE THREE EIGHT EGGMAN EIGHT
ZERO ABOUT. MCGUIRE IS THE SIX
TWO SO IT'S ALREADY OUT. SB
THREE NINETEEN MULLIN DOES THE
BILL IS DUE PASS VOTE IS
CURRENTLY SIX ZERO
BOERNER HORVATH BOERNER HORVATH
HI THREE OF US THREE OF US AYE
THE BOAT IS CURRENTLY EIGHT
ZERO SB. THREE NINETEEN EIGHT
ZERO OF MELINDA'S. AND THAT
BRINGS US BACK TO FOUR SEVEN
SIX. YEAH I THINK THE FIGURING
OUT FOR SOME THINGS.
UHHUH. NO
PROBLEM. GOOD EVENING. YOUR.
YEAH. THIS IS A NUMBER THAT.
THE LITTLE. ALL RIGHT- YEAH.
YEAH.
RIGHT. YEAH. YEAH. YEAH
UHHUH. YEAH. YOU DON'T GET ANY
ANSWERS THERE ARE. NONE. ZERO
YEAH. WE HAVE. I'M HERE. ONE
SIDE WITH THE CONSECUTIVE HOP
WE DO IT OKAY OUR CONSENT
CALENDAR THE BOARD IS CURRENTLY
SEVEN ZERO. THREE OF US
THREE OF US SIDE IT'S EIGHT
ZERO NOW.
MADAM CHAIR I
WITHDRAW RECONSIDERATION THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR VERY
KIND AND TRYING TO HELP OUR
FALLING OUT. OKAY WHAT THE
HEARING IS ADJOURNED MYSELF TO
DO THIS.